THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
ENVIRONMENT QUALITY TO ORDER.
AS YOU KNOW COLLEAGUES IN
RESPONSE TO THE COVETED.
EMERGENCY AND TO PROTECT OUR
PUBLIC AND LEGISLATORS AND
EMPLOYEES WE ARE LIMITING
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND
HEARING SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE. COVERING GUIDELINES. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THESE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE. THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS.
WE'RE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARING. EARLIER IN THE SENATE
CHAMBER. WITH SOME OF OUR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY OUR MEMBERS ATTENDING
REMOTELY TODAY ARE CENTER
SKINNER. CENTER STERN CENTER
BAIT BELIEVE. THAT RIGHT NOW.
SHE'S OKAY SHE'S NOT OKAY- WE
NOW KNOW THAT WE HAVE JEREMY
WOLFE AS PARTICIPATING WITH
SENATOR STERN COMMUNITY THE
STAFF PERSON WHO'S WITH CENTER
SKINNER IDENTIFY THEMSELVES.
MARGARET AND I NEVER HEARD.
OKAY MAYBE. OKAY HOPEFULLY
SHE'LL BE UP- BUT WILL HAVE TO-
OUR PROTOCOLS CALL FOR THE-
BOTH THE SENDER AND THE-
ASSISTING STAFFER TO IDENTIFY
THEMSELVES OKAY SO WE'LL WAIT
FOR CENTER. SKINNER. ALL RIGHT
LET'S SEE HERE. SO FOR JUST TO
LET PEOPLE KNOW ABOUT PUBLIC
ACCESS HERE TO THE CAPITAL-
WE'VE ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING ROOMS TO
THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING. REQUIREMENTS WILL
WE WILL BE USING. A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY TODAY REMOTELY. SO IF
YOU ARE NOT HERE PHYSICALLY
PRESENT IN THE CAPITAL AND YOU
LIKE TO MAKE A- PUBLIC COMMENT
ON ONE OF THE BILLS THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON
OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE IT WILL
BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN. I
WILL ALSO ANNOUNCE IT NOW
TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS.
944-291-6364 EIGHT FOUR FOUR
TWO NINE ONE. SIX THREE SIX
FOUR. AND THE ACCESS CODE IS
NINE ONE THREE EIGHT NINE SEVEN
SEVEN THAT'S NINE ONE THREE.
EIGHT NINE SEVEN SEVEN. FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW
THE TOP COVER THEM WORKS PLEASE
REFER TO THE SENATE INDOOR.
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN WE
MOVED PUBLIC COMMENT YOU WILL
BE PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR TO
DIAL ONE THEN IF ZERO FOUR
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. PRESS IS
ONLY ONE TIME IN WEEKS
PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR TO
ASSIGN YOU. A LINE NUMBER THIS.
CAN BE A SHORT WAIT ONCE YOU
RECEIVE A LINE NUMBER YOU WILL
WAIT IN THE QUEUE FOR THE
MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER AT THAT TIME YOU'LL BE A
NEW UNIT IN YOUR RADIO ADDRESS
COMMITTEE. PLEASE NOTE. PRESTI
YOU CLEARLY INTO ACOSTA FEED
YOU MUST TO THE- WATCH. GIVING
TESTIMONY. OVER THE PHONE IT IS
IMPORTANT WE HEAR YOU THANK YOU
YOUR. WE'RE OBVIOUSLY ALL
DEALING WITH LAG TIMES-
EVERYONE WHO'S BEEN FOLLOWING
THIS PROCESS KNOWS SO PLEASE BE
PATIENT WE HAVE ELEVEN BILLS
THAT ARE ON TODAY'S AGENDA WHEN
WE WERE ABLE TO GET ON TO THE
CAN CALENDAR AND I APPRECIATE
THE OFFERS FOR THEIR WORK. I'M
GETTING THE BILL'S ONTO THE-
CONCERN CAL RECEIVE PERSONAL
HARDWARE DISPATCH THOSE RIGHT
TO. FOUR FIVE EIGHT NINE. AND
TEN. SO BEFORE HER PRESENTATION
THE BILL'S ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
IF YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN HERE ALLEN HERE. DALLY
DALLY HERE HILL HERE HELLO HERE
SKINNER. STERN WHAT COUNTY HERE
MY COUNTY HERE WE HAVE A QUORUM.
FANTASTIC SO WE DO HAVE A
QUORUM. RIGHT THE CONTENT ON
THE MOVE BY SENATOR STERN- HILL.
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
TO THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
CONSENT CALENDAR ITEMS ARE TWO
THREE FOUR FIVE EIGHT NINE AND
TEN ALLEN HI ALAN I. DALY. I'M
SORRY I'M SORRY I CAN'T HEAR
YOU ON THE MIGHT TURN YOU MIGHT
BUY DALY AYE HILL. HI HILL AYE
SKINNER STERN WHY CASTING BY
WE'RE CASKEY I. OKAY THE
CONSENT CALENDAR WE'RE GOING TO
PUT ON CALL SO AS TO ALLOW
OTHER SENATORS TO ADD ON.
ALRIGHT WELL LET'S GO AHEAD AND
START WITH ITEM NUMBER ONE THIS
IS AB NINE NINETY FIVE BY A
CRISTINA GARCIA WE HAVE GOOD
MEMBER AND SENATOR PUBLIC
CASKEY. WHO WILL BE PRESENTING.
EIGHTY NINE NINETY FIVE. THE
CHAIR AS A STAFF REPORT POINTS
OUT ON PAGE NINE THE BUDGET ACT
OF TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN ONE THE
TRAILER BILLS CREATED LANGUAGE
FOR AN INDEPENDENT REVIEW PANEL
WITH THE TSC AFTER YEARS OF
MMHM PERFORMANCE. INCLUDING
EXTREMELY LONG PERMIT
PROCESSING TIMES FOR
ENFORCEMENT DELAYED SITE
REMEDIATION FAILURE TO RESPOND
TO PUBLIC CONCERNS IN. KEY IS
TO S. IN ATTENTION TO REDUCING
THE AMOUNT OF HE SAID THAT THE
HANDLING OF THE PRODUCTION OF.
HAZARDOUS WASTE HAS IN
CALIFORNIA- THERE HAVE BEEN
MANY OF LEGISLATIVE EFFORTS TO
IMPROVE THE DIFFERENT ASPECTS
OF THE TSA PROGRAM. AND SOME OF
THEM UNFORTUNATELY SOME OF THE
MEASURES HAVE BEEN VETOED BY.
THE ADMINISTRATION AND R. AS
THE WORK FOR A GLOBAL- INTERNAL
EFFORT TO IMPROVE THE FUNCTION
THE CHELSEA. DISCUSSION ARE
GOING ON AT EPA RIGHT NOW IN D.
DESPITE THE FUNDING OF THE-
THAT THE FEES ARE CHANGING THE
FEES IS AN INCREASE THE
FUNDING. IN ADDITION TO THE
PROBLEM PROBLEMATIC PROBLEMS
LAST YEAR DGSE WAS FACED WITH A
SUBSTANTIAL A STRUCTURAL
DEFICIT IN THE HAZARDOUS WASTE
CONTROL ACCOUNT WE'RE GOING TO
BE FOCUSING ON THE HAZARDOUS
WASTE AND- TOXIC. SINCE CONTROL
OF. LAST WE IT SEVENTY FIVE
FROM THE GENERAL FUND TO COVER
THE REGULATORY COSTS FOR JUST
THE LAST FISCAL YEAR. THEN THIS
YEAR. IT'S W. C. A. ALSO NEEDS
NINETEEN POINT FIVE WE IN THE-
IN THIS IN ORDER TO AVOID CUTS
THESE ARE JUST BARE BONES
FUNDING MECHANISM AS I INDICATE
INTIMATED THE TOXIC SUBSTANCE
CONTROL ACCOUNT. YES A CD IS
ALSO IN SUPER DEFICIT THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET. GIVE SEVEN SEVEN
POINT FIVE MILLION. SO THAT
THEY'RE NOT MAKING BELIEVE
THEIR- REPORT INSIGHTS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND
THEREBY CREATING SOME PUBLIC.
HEALTH RISKS BEYOND AND ABOVE
THOSE HEALTH RISKS FROM BACK
COVE IT SO THE PHYSICAL
CONDITION OF THE TSC MUST BE
FIXED TO HAVE A HEALTHY
DEPARTMENT THOSE NEGOTIATIONS
ARE ONGOING WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION AND MEMBERS OF
THE LEGISLATURE. HAS THAT THEIR
NOSE I'M ASSURING SUB TWO WERE
INTIMATELY INVOLVED WITH THE
EPA ON THIS BUT IT'S CLEAR THAT
HALF OF THE PROBLEM IS THE
STRUCTURAL CHANGES ARE THE
POLICY CHANGES WITH TEMPERATURE
FIVE EIGHT NINE FIVE. INCREASE
PRESS FRAME AND A WITH THE WITH
THE N. POLICE FACE THESE THINGS
SO WHAT THIS AB NINE NINE FIVE
TWO IT STARTS THESE HIGH LEVEL
ACTIONS TO RESET THE TSC INTO
THE APARTMENT THAT IS MORE
TRANSPARENT AND ACCOUNTABLE.
SPELLED OUT BY THE- THE
INDEPENDENT REVIEW PANEL TO
IMPROVE DGSE CEMEX FOUR
CATEGORIES OF CHANGES IT
CREATES A BOARD OF
ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY OF POLICY
SETTING AND PERMIT APPEALS.
BODY THAT WILL CONSIST OF FIVE
MEMBERS IT SECTION TO HELP
REFOCUS THE TSC CORE MISSION OF
CRITICAL RESPONSIBILITIES FOR
TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC.
ENVIRONMENT FROM TOXIC
SUBSTANCE BUT RESTORING
CONTAMINATED SITES ENFORCING
HAZARDOUS WASTE LAWS REDUCING
HAZARDOUS WASTE GENERATION IT
REALLY. BE TAPPED. THIS PATH TO
ARE YOU A- YES THESE FEES. OF
FIVE PENDING SO THAT WOULD
PROVIDE SUFFICIENT RE. FOR
TEACHERS IN THE CARRY OUT A FOR
MANDATE AND MAKES THAT STORE
CHECK TO IMPROVE AND SPEED UP
THE PERMITTING PROCESS THAT ARE
OUTLINED. IN THE STAFF REPORT.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS THIS.
BILL DOES NOT PROBLEM SOLVE ALL
THE PROBLEMS WITH PTSD HOWEVER
PLACES THE TSC A MORE SOLID
GROUND WITH THAT WE HAVE.
MEMBERS O SUPPORT IN SUPPORT
THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY ON
BEHALF AND I URGE AND I BOTH.
THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER
APPRECIATE THAT- S WHO DO WE
HAVE. WE HAVE INGRID BROSTROM
IS THE ASSISTANT DIRECTOR FOR
THE CENTER AND REYES PROPERTY
MAN VARMINT. HI INGRID IS
TESTIFYING IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
I BELIEVE SO LET'S GO OVER US
IS UP HERE OKAY HERE. WELCOME
THE CHAMBER YOU MAY BE SEATED
HI GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
INGRID BROSTROM ASSISTANT
DIRECTOR OF THE CENTER ON RACE
POVERTY IN THE ENVIRONMENT.
FIRST LET ME SAY THAT THIS IS A
LONG TIME IN COMING. WE HAVE
WAITED FOR THIS BILL AND THESE
REFORMS FOR YEARS. AND WHEN I
SAY WE I MEAN NOT ONLY MY
ORGANIZATION. BUT THE COUNTLESS
CALIFORNIANS WHO HAVE BEEN LET
DOWN BY DGSE DECADES. I MEAN
THE RESIDENT OF KETTLEMAN CITY.
WHO LIVE NEAR THE LARGEST
HAZARDOUS WASTE LANDFILL WEST
OF THE MISSISSIPPI. I MEAN THE
PRESIDENT OF THE LEANING WHO
ARE WAITING FOR A LONG OVERDUE
CLEANER. OF THE TCP AND PC
THAT'S THE NEED FOR HOMES AND
BUSINESSES. AND OF COURSE I
MEAN THE RESIDENTS OF BOYLE
HEIGHTS TO COMPLAIN OF LEAD
POISONING FROM THE FORMER
EXCITED FACILITY FOR YEARS
BEFORE I WENT TO THEIR PLEASE
SERIOUSLY. EIGHTY NINE NINE
FIVE SURVIVED A STRUCTURE FOR
DETAILS SEE TO INCREASE
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY.
AND ENSURE THAT IT IS MEETING
ITS OBLIGATIONS FOR ALL
STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING THE LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES AND
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. THE
LARGEST TALK TO BURDENS. AND
PROVIDE POLICIES SUCH AS
REINSTATING THE POLLUTION
PREVENTION PROGRAMS. AND
DEVELOPING A STATE WHAT
HAZARDOUS WASTE MANAGEMENT PLAN
THAT WILL HELP THE DEPARTMENT
BETTER PROTECTS BETTER PROTECT
RESIDENTS FROM PARK THE CAR.
THANK YOU FOR ALL THE
IMPROVEMENTS WE NEED TO SEE IT.
WE AS A STATE ALSO PROVIDED YOU
SEE THE TOOLS HE NEEDS TO
SUCCEED. WE MUST PLAN FOR THE-
BOTH THE NEEDS IN OUR STATE. WE
MUST STRUCTURE OUR FEES TO
INCENTIVIZE HAZARDOUS WASTE
REDUCTIONS SO THAT ALL
CALIFORNIANS CAN BENEFIT FROM A
LESS TOXIC SOCIETY. AND WE NEED
TO MAKE SURE THE AGENCY IS
SOLVENT. AND THE POLLUTERS NOT
THE PUBLIC THE ONLY PAYS FOR
THE COSTS. ASSOCIATED WITH
HAZARDOUS WASTE GENERATION AND
DISPOSAL. EIGHTY NINE NINE FIVE
IS A LONG TIME COMING. AS A
STATE WE MUST PRIORITIZE
FIXING. IN FUNDING THIS
TROUBLED AGENCY. THE STATUS QUO
IS NOT GOOD ENOUGH. THE COST OF
INACTION IS SIMPLY TOO GREAT
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR ITEM
THANK YOU. MUCH INGRID BISHOP
THAT- LET'S NOW. TAKE UP TO WE
HAVE. SOMEONE ELSE HEY OKAY. HI
MORE NATURE MEMBERS ON THE END
OF US BECAUSE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA BERMAN SAYS ITS
ALLIANCE RUN STARTS ON SITE FOR
TO HAVE A- THE WITH THE CAL.
BERMAN JUSTICE ALLIANCE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
BASED ON THE COMMENTS OF MY
COLLEAGUE INGER BOSTON JUST
INDICATED AND THANK YOU FOR THE
TIME AND- FOR WORKING ON THIS
HUGE EFFORT THAT WE'VE BEEN
WORKING ON FOR SO MANY YEARS.
THANK YOU FOR THE- THANK YOU SO
MUCH. OKAY ANYONE ANYONE ELSE.
HERE IN THIS OKAY INTEREST OKAY
LET'S LET'S GO TO THE- WE'RE
NOT GOING TO GO TO ALL OF OUR
VARIOUS ROOMS SO WE'RE GONNA GO
TO NINE TWENTY FORTY EIGHT IST
IS ANYBODY. NO NOBODY THERE
OKAY. LET'S NEXT GO TO THE
TELECONFERENCE. LINE. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. PROBABLY WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. GOOD
MORNING SHARE MANY OF HIS WE
ALSO THE HEALTH CHAMBER
COMMERCE. WE ARE A POSITION OF
AUTHORITY AMENDED INDUSTRY. AND
BETTER WHAT HAD BEEN NOTED THAT
THE LEGISLATURE HAS.
CONTINUALLY PROVIDED THE- ONE.
OF THE FINE COULD NOT RESULTING
IN A REFORM THAT ISSUES THAT
YOU BACKLOG AND THE LEADING A
GROUP BOTH THE BEACH APPRECIATE
YOUR FELT. ON RUSSIA AND WE
WILL FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE TO RESULT
SOME OF OUR REMAINING ISSUES
THANK YOU. THANK YOU THANK YOU
WILL NOW GET A LINE NUMBER
SEVENTY SEVEN ZERO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS DONNED KHAKI
WITH MAKE YOU CAP CAN ASSESS
YET SOMEHOW CALIFORNIA COUNCIL
FOR ENVIRONMENTAL AND ECONOMIC
BALANCE- WEALTHY DOES NOT HAVE
A FORMAL POSITION ON EIGHTY
NINE NINE FIVE AS OF YET. TO
WORK VERY COLD. AND PROACTIVELY
WITH THE OP DOC ON MEANINGFUL
GOVERNANCE PROGRAMMATIC AND
FISCAL REFORM OF THE APARTMENT
OF TOXIC SUBSTANCES CONTROL.
HOW WE CONTINUE TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION ABOUT FURTHER
REFINEMENTS ARE NOT ONLY ON
GOVERNANCE AND PROGRAMMATIC
REFORM ASPECT. BUT ALSO WORKING
THROUGH THE FISCAL ASPECTS OF
THINGS AS WELL ARE WE HOPE TO
FOLLOW UP WITH ADDITIONAL
INSIGHT AND ACCEPT WITH YOU.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU THANK YOU
ON A LOT NUMBER. FIVE NINE
ZERO. IT MORE MELISSA ROMERO
THE HELP LEGAL COMPANIES VOTERS
AND STRONG APART. THANK YOU
WILL GO TO LINE NUMBER EIGHTY
FIVE EIGHT FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING CIRCUIT ON
BEHALF OF THE NATIONAL ACTION
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT YEAH. THANK
YOU WILL GET A LOT NUMBER FIFTY
THREE FIVE THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. SURE NUMBER THANK YOU TO
CREDIT WITH THE NATIONAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL IN
CONCORD NC NINETY FIVE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR HER
CONTINUED LEADERSHIP ON THIS
IMPORTANT AND LONG OVERDUE SHE-
YOU'LL GET A LINE NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED ONE ZERO ZERO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. YES HELLO THIS IS A
LITTLE WITH THE ENVIRONMENTAL
WORKING GROUP- IN. EXTRA ARE
STRONG SUPPORT STILL. THANK YOU
WILL I NUMBER EIGHTY THREE
EIGHT THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI GOOD MORNING NUMBER OF THE
LOWER COMMONS HERE CAL AND
STRONG FOR THE BILL. THANK YOU
WE HAVE THREE OR MAYBE A CUTE
LITTLE AYE NUMBER NINETY FOUR
NINE FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
RIGHT BACK WITH A BRAND MAKE
KAYLEE ON BEHALF OF REPUBLIC
SERVICES AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MY NUMBER NINETY SEVEN NINE
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS ANDREA VENTURA
WITH CLEAN WATER ACTION IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU WILL GO TO
LINE NUMBER NINETY SIX NINE SIX
ZERO IS OPEN. THANK YOU ENSURE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS CHRIS OUR
BEHALF OF CLEAN HARBORS AND
SAFETY CLEAN WE HAVE THE
SUPPORT OF AMENDED POSITION FOR
EIGHTY NINE NINETY FIVE. WE
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING OUR
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE OFFICE
OFFICE. THE ADDITIONAL. ECLIPSE
WATER BILL IN ITS CURRENT FORM
NOT A HARBORS MARKERS AND THAT
OVER THE MEASURE PROVIDES FOR
MONEY THE IMPORTANT NEXT TO THE
HARD NUMBERS TO RIGHT AND ALICE
ENTRANCE CAL THE STATION MAKING
CALIFORNIA HE'S OUT NOW THE
BARS TO PROGRAM MATTER STATE. I
AM NOT BIRD LATER. PROGRESS IS
MADE TODAY THAT WOULD
PROTECTING. HELLO SO. AND
WORKING OIL. PRO WHICH FOR
YEARS SERVED AS A MOM PROTEGER
RECORD HAS ATTRACTED. PUBLIC
AND PRIVATE ABOUT CRITICAL RISK
IS IMPRESSED. AND AS A RESULT
OF THE CHANGE THAT WAY WHEN. BE
FIVE SIX BACKING. THOUSAND
NINE. AN ACT AS WHAT YOU ON THE
SITE THE END OF BY EACH PLACED
ON LUKOIL MANY. INCLUDING OUR
CELL. THE SUPPORTER NUMBERS TO
RECYCLING. AS SUCH WE STRONG
BELIEVE ANY AND I. OF THE STATE
HAZARDOUS WASTE MANAGE. AND
RECYCLING. OF COP. NOT UNDER OR
ANYWHERE ONE ANOTHER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AS A WRITER YOU MAY
PLACE YOURSELF IN A QUEUE BY
PLACING ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD WE HAVE ONE
REMAINING YOU WILL GO TO LIKE
NUMBER ONE HUNDRED EIGHT. ONE
ZERO EIGHT LINE IS OPEN. WITH
ZERO. A LOT. AND I JUST WANTED
TO ARE LETTING OUR STRONG
SUPPORT THE FELT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AT THIS POINT WE HAVE
EXHAUSTED THE QUEUE NO ONE HAS
READ CUTE. SINCE I GIVE A LOT
OF TRIMMING SHE- WELL. EVERYONE
GIVING US THEIR TESTIMONY OUR
GO TO OPPOSITION I BELIEVE WE
HAVE CHIU WHITE WHOSE WITH THE
RESOURCE MANAGEMENT ASSOCIATION
ON THE LINE TO VOICE OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL. YES HELLO- MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THAT STRUCK QUITE I'M
A SENIOR ADVISER WITH MEN THAT
HELPS JOKES ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA RESOURCE MANAGEMENT
ASSOCIATION- RIGHT WELL IN THE
PAST PRESIDENT OF MANY YEARS
AGO- THE CALIFORNIA RESOURCE.
MANAGEMENT ASSOCIATION WE MUST.
RESPECTFULLY AND ACTUALLY
RELUCTANTLY UPHOLSTERY. EIGHTY
NINE NINETY NINE NINE FIFTY
FIVE. NINETY FIVE OTHER BIG
YEAH ALTHOUGH WE BELIEVE THAT
REFORM IS DEFINITELY WARRANTED
AT THE TNC IT MUST BE BALANCED
THAT HAZARDOUS WASTE GENERATED
IN CALIFORNIA IS PROPERLY AND
SAFELY MANAGE TO CALIFORNIA'S
STANDARDS RATHER THAN CURRENT
SITUATION WHERE AS MUCH AS 50%
OR MORE OF HAZARDOUS WASTE IS
EXPORTED TO OTHER JURISDICTIONS
MANY OF. WHICH ARE MUCH LESS
EDGMON STANDARDS THAT CAL.
RESOURCE MANAGEMENT IS FORMALLY
THE HAZARDOUS WASTE ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA AND WAS
INCORPORATED. EIGHT NINETEEN
EIGHTY FOUR. HELLO ARE AT OUR
MAY IS COMPRISED OF INDIVIDUALS.
THAT'S WHAT CALIFORNIA
HAZARDOUS WASTE MANAGEMENT
STANDARDS WE ARE CONCERNED-
THAT THE MATERIALS UP NEVER
HAVE THOSE WAYS ARE EXPORTED
FROM CALIFORNIA TO THE OTHER
JURISDICTIONS IN LARGE PART DUE
TO THE EXISTING EXTREMELY
LENGTHY DIFFICULT AND EXPENSIVE
PROCESS OF SIDING OR EXPANDING
HAS THE SPACE OPERATIONS YOU
CALIFORNIA TO MEET CALIFORNIA
STANDARDS. OTHER JURISDICTIONS
ACTIVELY SUBJECT CALIFORNIA HAS
OF THOSE WAYS TO FAR LESS
MANAGE LESS STRINGENT
MANAGEMENT STANDARDS. AS A
RESULT A LOT OF ACTION- WASTE
IS EXPORTED TO SURROUNDING
STATES AND JURISDICTIONS.
EXISTING CALIFORNIA STATE FEES
FOR THE MANAGEMENT OF HAZARDOUS
WASTE IN CALIFORNIA ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY HIGHER THAN
FEET BY MANY OTHERS INJURED.
CALIFORNIA FEES CAN BE AVOIDED
SIMPLY BY EXPORTING WASTE TWO
OTHER ADJACENT STATES OR
JURISDICTIONS. SO WE HAVE A
NUMBER OF CONCERNS ABOUT THE
BILL I WILL TRY TO MENTALLY OF
MENTION THEM BRIEFLY- WE ARE
LATER IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
TO CREATING A BOARD. HOWEVER IF
THERE IS A BOARD I CREATED IT
MUST BE OF POP UP POPULATED BY
BUT MORE MORE STRINGENT.
REQUIREMENTS FOR- BOARD MEMBER
QUALIFICATIONS AND ARTICULATED
SOME OF THOSE QUALIFICATIONS
THE EX EMPLOYER ARE VERY WITH
HAVE TO PROVIDE. ARGUMENT. WE
WOULD- HOPE THAT THERE IS A
COMPREHENSIVE HAZARDOUS WASTE
MANAGEMENT PLANET WHICH IS
BADLY NEEDED THE CURRENT
LANGUAGE. EIGHTY NINE NINETY
FIVE SEEMS TO FOCUS PRIMARILY
ON- REVIEW OF PERMITTING WHICH
IS APPROPRIATE BUT WE THINK THE
AUTHORITY OF THE BOARD
ESTABLISH SHOULD BE MUCH
BROADER TO ENSURE THAT ALL
POLICY REGULAR. ENFORCED AT
TIMES ARE SUBJECT WILL APPEAL
TO THAT BOARD. THE HOUSING
ISSUE WE MANAGEMENT PLAN AND
FEE STRUCTURE MUST COOLEY
ARTICULATE THE STATE'S POLICY
ON ACTUAL HAZARDOUS WASTE
MANAGEMENT OTHER JURISDICTIONS.
REGULATIONS ARE SICK LESS
STRINGENT THAN CALIFORNIA'S.
REYES REGULATORY STRUCTURE. THE
IT IS PROPOSED. PERMITTING TIME
FRAMES IN THE LIKE THE DO NOT
NAY SENSE WHICH IS THAT
LANGUAGE TO CORRECT RECALL IS A
GOOD DAY WERE WE BELIEVE THAT.
ACCORDING FOR THE RIGHT OF
WATER QUALITY ARE PRESSED WTH
THE STATE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD. REGIONAL WATER
CONTROL BOARD WE NO OBJECTION
TO- DGSE PROVIDING INPUT TO
THOSE BOARDS BUT WE WOULD HOPE
THAT. ULTIMATE LEGISLATION THAT
WOULD PROVIDE REFORM FOCUSES
WATER QUALITY ISSUES ON THE
STATE AND REGIONAL WATER
QUALITY CONTROL. WE BOUGHT HAS
BEAT THE REVIEW OF THE MUST BE
PROVIDED TO A NEW. THIS
WOULDN'T WILL MAKE FINANCE
ASSURANCE CORRECTIVE ACTION
ENFORCEMENT ACTIVITIES SHOULD
BE SUBJECT TO BOARD REVIEW IF
THERE IS A BOARD. WELL
CONCERNED ABOUT RATHER THAN
RUSH CORRECTIVE ACTION
ESTIMATES THE MEDIATION ACTIONS
WORKING ABOUT SOME OF THE TIME
USERS. THE LEGISLATION.
ARTICULATED ERICOM LETTER WE
BELIEVE THAT DDS REVIEW OF
SPECIFIC COSTESTIMATES MUST BE
OBJECTIVE AND ALSO SUBJECT TO
YOU BY THE BOARD. AND WHAT. THE
PROVISIONS OF. AND FIVE ARE
INCONSISTENT WITH OTHER
CORRECTIVE ACTION AUTHORITIES
THAT ARE ALREADY PROVIDED IN
THE STATUTE. IN CONCLUSION- WE-
ACTUALLY RELUCTANTLY AS I
MENTIONED HAVE TO OPPOSE AB
NINETEEN NINETY FIVE AS
CURRENTLY PROPOSED- UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION- WILL REMAIN
UNLESS WE'RE ABLE TO SEE SOME
AMENDMENTS CAN BE FULL.
THRESHING SOME CARD SIR OUR
WAGERED MORE FULLY IN OUR
COMMENT LET WE APPRECIATE YEAH.
TO SPEAK WITH YOU TODAY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SOME HI IS THERE
ANYONE ELSE WHO IS A LEAD
WITNESS IN OPPOSITION. I DON'T
BELIEVE WE HAVE ANYONE IN
TWENTY FOUR YOU'RE ON THE PHONE
LINES BUT PLEASE CORRECT ME IF
I'M CORRECT. IT LOOKS LIKE
TWENTY FOUR HOUR LIMITATION ON
THE TELECONFERENCE PHONE LINES
YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WE DO HAVE ONE IN THE
QUEUE AT THIS TIME WE'LL GO TO
NUMBER. HUNDRED SEVENTY THAT
ONCE. AHEAD YEAH BECAUSE I NOT
SEE. YEAH I'M NOT SEEING ANYONE
TO MORE INJURED MANY MEMBER. I
APOLOGIZE. I WAS ACTUALLY. CALL
INTO SUPPORT IS NICOLE OKAY.
AGAINST WASTE. AND WE WANT TO
THANK ALL AND THE- FOR THE PART
WORK ON THE ISSUE OVER YEARS
AND. RIGHT OR- OKAY THANK YOU
FOR. I WANT FORTY SO GO AHEAD
AND HERE FOR PAPPAS OF THE
PHONE LINES. WHAT YOU GET IF
YOU'RE OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO TO
HAVE YOUR VOICE HEARD THAT'S.
ONE ZERO. THERE IS NO ONE
SHOWING UP AT THIS TIME SIR
OKAY SO WE'VE HEARD FROM
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION WE
APPRECIATE ALL OF THE VERY
CONSTRUCTIVE TESTIMONY WHY
DON'T WE OPEN UP THE FLOOR TO
QUESTIONS COMMENTS DEBATE. FROM
THE COMMITTEE. YEAH I CALL IT
YOU KNOW IF WE HAVE ANYONE
WHO'S- JOINING US REMOTELY WHO
HAS ANY COMMENTS. I ASSUME IT'S
CENTER CASKEY- WOULD OF THE
BILL I DO WANT TO JUST GOING TO
HAVE TO PERSONALLY THANK THE
AUTHOR- CINEMA CRISTINA GARCIA
FOR HER HARD WORK IN IN IN- ON
DGSE REFORM IT IS BEEN A LONG
AND WINDING ROAD THIS AT AN
ALLUDED. AND DONE. I DESERVES
STATION FOR HARD WORK IN THIS
AREA AND I'M REALLY THE BILL'S
GOING TO. PROVIDE SOME MUCH
NEEDED. I OVERSIGHT POLICY
DIRECTION- TO THE FOLKS WHO CAN
TRUST WITH KEEPING US SAFE FROM
HAZARDOUS WASTE SO. WITH THAT
I'M CERTAINLY SUPPORTED BILL
TODAY IT'S BEEN MOVED BY CINEMA
CASKEY- THIRTY FIVE CONTROL MY
WE CALL THE ROLL. DO YOU PASSED
THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. I REMEMBER ONE
EIGHTY NINE NINE FIVE BY KURT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CRISTINA GARCIA
THE MOTION TO PASS TO THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
ALLEN HI M. I. L. A. DALLYING.
NOT VOTING TALLY NOT VOTING
HELLO HI HILL AYE. SKINNER AND
STERN WHY CASKEY HI MY COUNTY I.
OKAY WILL HOLD THAT OPEN FOR
OTHER MEMBERS TO ADD ON- BUT WE
DO APPRECIATE YOUR- YOUR VOTES
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION CENTER CASKEY.
LET'S MOVE ON NOW TO. FILE ITEM
SIX THIS IS ANOTHER. CASKEY
UTILITY PLAY HI THIS IS A CELL
NUMBER QUIRKS AB TWENTY TWO
NINETY SIX RELATING TO OUR
WATER RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD
AND THE FUNDING STABILIZATION
PROGRAMS YOU MAY PROCEED WHEN
READY. OUR TASK. THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR THIS BILL WILL
ALLOW COUNTIES BUT LOCAL
OVERSIGHT OF SMALL DRINKING
WATER SYSTEMS TO ELECT TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE FUNDING
STABILIZATION PROGRAM
ADMINISTERED BY THIS WATER
BOARD HAS BEEN A LOT OF
DISCUSSION WE KNOW A LOT OF THE
FAILING. ASSIST LOCAL OFTEN
OFFICE REGULATE SMALL DRINKING
WATERS IN THIRTY COUNTIES IN
THE IN CALIFORNIA ACCOUNTING
FOR OVER HALF OF THE PUBLIC
DRINKING WATER SYSTEMS IN THE
STATE. AS HIGHLIGHTED IT STAFF
REPORT COMPARED TO LARGER
SYSTEM SMALL WATER SYSTEMS
OFFER REQUIRED MORE RESOURCES
PER CUSTOMER TO ENSURE
COMPLIANCE WITH THE STATE OF
WATER ARE CALLED REQUIREMENTS
BUT THEY ALSO. THAT'S
REGULATORY FEE I MEAN YOU SMALL
WATER SYSTEMS ARE LIKELY TO
LACK TECHNICAL FINANCIAL AND
MANAGERIAL CAPACITY SOLVE
ISSUES AND RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
BULK OF THE STATE'S WATER THE
FILE. SO WITH THAT THIS AB DO
NOT. YOU KNOW IS CONCERNED THE
KERN PUBLIC CRISIS IS
EXACERBATED THE NEED FOR THIS
BILL AND MANY OF THE SMALL FEE
FOR PERSISTENCE ARE BEING HIT
HARD WITH THE ECONOMIC IMPACT A
LITTLE BIT WE NEED SOME
STABILISATION WHICH IS
PROVIDED. AB TWO TWO NINE. THIS
SYSTEM SEWER RISK. SEVENTY
THREE THE RIVERSIDE TO THE
STATES SO IT'S A LIFELINE AND
WE HAVE WITH THE- THE COOPERS
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH MINISTERS
JUSTIN MILAN EMBRY AND WARMER
WITH THE RURAL COUNTIES. I PORT
MISTER I URGE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH ALL RIGHT WE'VE GOT JUSTIN
I KNOW THINK A MERION IS NOT ON
THE LINE AND- BUT LET'S START
WITH THE- MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR HEARING THE
BILL AND A SPECIAL THANK YOU TO
SENATOR CASKEY I KNOWS THIS
ISSUE WELL- FOR STANDING IN FOR
OUR. RECORDS ASIAN AND YOU ARE
NOW AS A WASTE DONE IT JOB. IN
OUTLINING THE- THAT THESE LOCAL.
PRIVACY AGENCY AS CALLED THE
DRINKING WATER OVERSIGHT FOLKS
FACES THE LOCAL LEVEL. I THINK
THE ANALYSIS DESCRIBES THE OVER
ARCHING CHALLENGES IN THE
PROBLEMS LET ME JUST HIT ON
THREE THINGS THAT YOU ARE NOW
THE STATE'S. MOST OF. USE OF
REESE. WE'RE NOT LOOKING A
BAILOUT OF FAILING- AGENCY WE
LOOK INTO THE MOST EFFICIENT
WAY OF GETTING. WE'RE BEING
DONE BY THE STATE ALTHOUGH.
TAKE YOUR DAYS IS ACTUALLY
PROGRAM PEOPLE ONE TO KEEP CON
LOCAL THAT PERFECT GAME TO SO
THIS IS STILL CALLED MAN THE-
SMALL. PRINT USE THAT MANY OF
THESE JURISDICTIONS CARE AND
THIRDLY BASED ON THE- AMENDMENT
SPEECH OF. A KNOW NEGOTIATIONS
WITH THE WATER DISTRICTS AND
THEY HAVE TO BE A SHOWING OF
NEED WE FIND HER YEARS. ONE
THEY DON'T CHARGE. WE WILL GET
THE STATE TO DO THE I'M NOT
SAYING I THINK PROBABLY MUST.
WE HAVE NO OTHER PUBLICATIONS
NOT FROM THE WATER AGENTS THAT
IN THE OF THIS THAT. HIS WORK.
DONE WHETHER IT'S DONE BY I BY
DATE. IS LIKELY TO BE AN
INCREASE OVER THE YEAR AS THE
WORKLOAD INCREASE THIS AND AS
WE TRY. IS A HORRIBLE DAY DID
ALL DRINKING WATER PROGRAM.
ACROSS THE STATE ESPECIALLY
WITH DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
ARE JUST LIKE DISTRICT PLEASE
DON'T DELAY THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF THIS BILL. WE PLAY IN THE
APPROPRIATIONS FUNDS LARGELY
BECAUSE OF IT GRAYSON. COLLEGE
WE SOME TIME TO FIGURE OUT BEST
TO OFFER THIS PROGRAM. BUT LOS
WEEK WAS ANOTHER BIG. OF THE
ADEQUATE FUNDING AND AS AMADOR
COUNTY HAD TO BAIL OUT AND
SURRENDER THE PROGRAM BACK TO
THE STATE WHICH MEANS IT. SMALL
ESPECIALLY THE DISADVANTAGED.
THIS BECAUSE THEY NOW HAVE TO
RELY THE STATE AND IMMORAL
REMOTE OVERSIGHT FROM THE STATE
WATER RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD
SO FOR THOSE REASONS WE DRIVERS
AND THANK YOU POSTED A WORKOUT
CAN YOU OPEN AND YOU ARE EXTENT
IN OUR- ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
MUCH I THINK WE- MARIANNA'S. ON
THE SO LET'S NOW HEAR FROM
MERION. WATER DAM. CHAIRMEN
THANK YOU I WOULDN'T A LINE
MIKE MR LOW THE AND JUST AND-
THAT OVER THE PAST SEVERAL
YEARS THE PROGRAM COSTS FOR THE
LAWN JURISDICTION HAVE BACKED
OUT THE DEBATE AND HAS BEEN
AGGRAVATED BY. ASIAN AND ARAB
YOU MIGHT EXT. WE BELIEVE THE
MEASURE WELL AND SHE THAT ALL
CARILLO. EVERY OF WHETHER FROM
LARGER DISTRICTS FROM- URBAN OR
RURAL AREAS WILL CONTINUE TO
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO ACCESS.
STATE AND COOK BREAKING ONE- I
WOULD THIS MEASURE WILL ALLOW
COUNTIES JUST EXTRA TOOL IF YOU
WANT MORE FLEXIBILITY IN HOW
THEY THEIR NAME. DID YOU. AND
WE THINK THERE'S NO NOW. JUST
TO REALLY SOME OF THE- AND YOU
LAUNDRY WATER SYSTEM. THAT IS
CURRENTLY. AVELING I OF THE CAN
YOU I JUST KNOW THAT WHILE
AMADOR COUNTY. ALLEGING THAT
PARTICULAR CATEGORY WE SEE A
TREND LINE THAT CONTINUES SO WE
THINK THE NEED FOR THE PROGRAM
CONTINUED TO INCREASE OVER
TIME- WITH THAT MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU FOR THE. OPPORTUNITY
EIGHT. RIGHT OKAY THANK YOU SO
MUCH. I WOULD TO NOW TAKE THE
CHECK PRESS TO OPEN UP TO
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT TESTIMONY
FOR YOU GO TO CHECK OUT ROOM
TWENTY FORTY TO SEE IF THIS
DEBATE IT. OKAY STILL NOBODY
THERE SO LET'S NOW OPEN UP TO
THE PHONE LINES- THIS IS FOR
SUPPORT MY MODERATOR IF YOU
PLEASE PREVENTIVA JUST WHEN
TESTIFIED PORT OF AB TWENTY TWO
NINETY SIX. WE WILL BEGIN.
CERTAINLY LAYS DOWN ON THE
FOLLOWING. ISSUE VOICE SUPPORT
FOR THIS BILL YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN IT IS ZERO AT THIS TIME.
WE DO HAVE ONE THAT IS ALREADY
IN QUEUE WE'LL GO TO LINE
NUMBER EIGHTY NINE. EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS. ONE MOMENT PLEASE. I
DO APOLOGIZE I'M UNABLE TO OPEN
LINE EIGHTY NINE FOR SOME
REASON ONE MOMENT PLEASE. IT
APPEARS THEY REMOVE THEMSELVES
FROM THE QUEUE OKAY ANYONE ELSE
MODERATOR IS THAT IT. ACTUALLY
WE NOW HAVE A EIGHTY NINE BACK
LET'S GO TO EIGHTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN WELCOME BACK TO
NINETEEN FAIR PATIENTS THIS IS.
THANK YOU THIS IS KATHY BURKE
WITH THAT THERE'S THAT THE NO
CALIFORNIA FOR. OKAY THANK YOU
SO MUCH. I THINK THAT'S IT IS
OUTSIDE ZERO TO PLACE YOURSELF
IN A QUEUE. IMAGE ONE AND PLACE
YOURSELF THANK YOU FOR SUPPORT.
ARLIS WE HEAR ANY OTHER
ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY- FOLKS
WANTED A MODERATOR WE'RE GONNA
MOVE TO OPPOSITION. WE HAVE
SCOTT KAUFMAN IS THAT IS THE
DIRECTOR FOR THE HOWARD JARVIS
TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION WAS
OPPOSITE AB. TWENTY TWO NINETY
SIX MISTER KAUFMAN UNIVERSITY
AND- WHEN RIGHT. I THANK HELLO
I AM STUCK OFTEN LISTED RECORD
HOWARD JARVIS TAXPAYERS
ASSOCIATION WE OPPOSED TO BE
TWO TWO NINE SIX AB CAN I TAKE
OUT MY CLASS. THE WATER BOARD
WELL DETERMINE. ANTHONY THIS
CHANGE SURE LOWER RATE GENERAL
FUND CALL ON LIKE EIGHTY THE TO
THIS BILL HELLO THIS MANDATE.
FIND THE GENERAL THIS APPROACH
SOLUTION BECAUSE CLEAN WATER IS
A MATTER WHY CAN YOU FIND TAX.
HOWEVER WE APPRECIATE IT OKAY
OFFERED BY AB TWO TWO NINE. THE
LANG CONTINUES MAN THAT EACH
HEALTH WATER AGENCY. EACH FEES
TO PORT. PROBABLE RESULT WORRY
BE SOME TO PROGRAM FURTHER THEY
WILL BE RECEIVING A ADDITIONAL
FROM THE SUN AND UNDOUBTABLY
COST TO RATE WILL INCREASE. WE
ASK TO OPPOSE AB AB THREE NINE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU YOU SO MUCH MISTER KAUFMAN.
ALL RIGHT ANYONE WHO WANTS TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL THIS IS AB TWENTY TWO
NINETY SIX I DON'T BELIEVE
ANYONE IN TWENTY FORTY. LET'S
TURN IT UP. TO SEE IF THERE'S A
ON THE FOR I WOULD LIKE TO
VOICE OPPOSITION. IF WE DON'T
HAVE A PHONE LINE THROUGH WHICH
IS- VOICE OPPOSITE AB TWO TWO
NINE SIX YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. THERE IS NO ONE
SHOWING UP AT THIS TIME SIR.
OKAY THANK YOU SO MUCH. OUR
GREAT WELL LET'S NOW OPEN UP TO
YOU THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. THE THOUGHTS
QUESTIONS CONCERNS ISSUES. HI
SOON THE PRESENTER WILL WANT TO
MOVE THE BILL YES CENTER CASKEY.
M. OF THE BILL OKAY GREAT. THIS
IS A IS A STAFF REPORT. OF
POINTS OUT THIS IS A
CONTINUATION OF. A SAID STARTED
LAST YEAR WOODS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PORK AND AB FOUR OH TWO IT
PROVIDES THE PROVIDE IT UP TILL
SERVICES FUNDING AS THE
OPPOSITION'S POINT OUT. LIES
NINE. WITH THAT ORIGINAL VOTE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER CASKEY.
I LET'S SO JUST TO LET PEOPLE
KNOW CENTER HILL HAD TO HE'S
CHAIRING THE LABOR TO NOW. WE
ON SO WELL WE ONLY HAVE THREE
MEMBER PRESENT BUT WE CAN CARRY
ON WITH THE VOTES AND WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR FOLKS
FINAL. BEFORE AB THANK YOU
NINETY SIX. OKAY LARA I TO
NUMBER SIX A. B. NINE FIVE
SENATE PUBLISHED. I DON'T KNOW
SIXTY SIX FIVE MEMBER THE
MOTION IS PASSED TO THE SENATE
FOR COMMITTEE ALAN HI ALAN I AM
NOT VOTING DALLY NOT VOTING
HILL SKINNER. MY COUNTY HI
HOUSE. OKAY FROM SO WE'RE GONNA
THAT OPEN FOR FOLKS TO ADD ON
LET'S NOT GO TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRIEDMAN SHE'S HERE TO PRESENT.
TO BILLS THE IS FOR AB TWENTY.
THREE THAT'S ITEM IN YOUR PACK
MEMBERS INITIAL THAT. THE
MILLER. THIRTY TWO SEVEN NINE.
AND THESE ARE BOTH RELATING TO
A SEQUEL. AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRIEDMAN YOU MAY PROCEED WHEN
READY THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
NUMBERS I WANT TO FIRST THANK
YOU AND YOUR STAFF FOR YOUR
WORK ON THE STATE LAW THAT TO
ACCEPT THE PROPOSED COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS. I RECOGNIZE. AUTHORED
SOME THIRTY PERSON MIGHT NOT ON
SURE START IT'S ON IT'S ON
MILLION YEAH IT ALSO LIKE TO
READ. MY ALL AND REMEMBER CHIU
AS WELL AS THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OF PLANNING RESEARCH AND
THE DIVERSE COLD IF SUPPORTERS
FOR THEIR PARTNERSHIP.
CALIFORNIA FACE UNPRECEDENTED
HOW AND CLIMATE CRISES. AND OUR
PLACE IN ADDRESSING THE
CHALLENGES HAS BEEN WAY TOO
SLOW. AB TWENTY THREE TWENTY
THREE IS INTENDED TO HELP
ADDRESS BOTH CRISES BY ENSURING
THAT SEQUENCE IN MINING. FOR
HOUSING PROJECTS WORKED AS
INTENDED. AND THAT WELL PLANNED
HOUSING TO. DROP NOT DELAYED A-
WE DO THIS NOT ADDING MORE
LAYERS OF A- TO THE ALREADY
COMPLEX ARRAY OF SEACOR
PROVISIONS FOR HOUSING. BUT
RATHER BY MAKING THE EXISTING
HOUSING EXEMPTIONS MORE
CONSISTENT OBJECTIVE AND FIND
WITH HOUSING EMPLOYMENT GOALS.
AB TWENTY THREE TWENTY THREE
SUPPORT HOUSING ADVOCATES AND
BUSINESS GROUPS PLANNERS AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND
ENVIRONMENTAL ACTIVISTS. WE
HAVE WORKED WITH EVERYONE FROM
THE PROCESS AND RESOLVE MANY OF
THE ISSUES THAT HAVE BEEN
BROUGHT TO US. WE WILL CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH THE STAKEHOLDERS
AS THE BILL MOVES FORWARD.
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT BY PHONE
OR NYC MARC RICH WHICH THE
OFFICE OF MAKING WITH THE
OFFICE OF MAYOR ERIC GARCETTI
THAT LA MAYOR ERIC GARCETTI FOR
THOSE OF YOU WHO DON'T. HOLLY
FROM HABITAT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER CHAIR. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH LET'S GO TO YOUR LEAD.
THE TESTIMONY. I BELIEVE AND
MAKES ON THE PHONE SO IT'S
HOLLY. HI GOOD MORNING- THAT
THAT THAT GOOD AFTERNOON OR
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
HONORABLE MEMBERS. MY NAME IS
MARISSA CHIN AND JOINING YOU ON
THIS MORNING ON BEHALF OF
VALLEY MAYOR ERIC GARCETTI. OR
AND THEN WE BUILT THREE THREE
THIS BILL WOULD CLARIFY THE
QUALIFICATIONS FOR USED VEHICLE
EXEMPTION FOR TRANSIT PRIORITY
PROJECTS THROUGH THE- DENTAL
COMMUNITY STRATEGY. WHICH IS A
CRITICAL NEED FOR LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS. MORE SUSTAINABLE
GROWTH PATTERNS. INCLUDING A
JOB AND AFFORDABLE. TRANSIT AND
MOST. FOR LOS ANGELES THE BILL.
WITH MANTA MY- THE- LA PLANS
ARE PART BY HEART WHO FOR
FUTURE DEVELOPMENT AND MEREKA
HE HAS PLACED A HIGH PRIORITY
ON AT CAN YOU PLAN THAT HAVING
MATTER THE BILL WILL ENSURE.
THAT OUR COMPANY. EIGHT WELL.
YOU'RE RIGHT YOU LEARN ON THE
INTERNET BY THE CITY THAN
REQUIRE BEYOND AND PART OF IT I
PROPERTY IT WORK TO A THE USE
YOU CAN ACTUALLY CLAN EIGHT AND
LOCAL. WORKING CREE HOUSING
PRODUCTION A REDUCE GREENHOUSE
GAS. AND WE'RE THE MILLIONS
DOLLARS ANNUALLY IF THE THAT
AND COMPLETE THE NECESSARY IN
MARIN REVIEW UNDER CEQA.
ELIMINATION OF DUPLICATE. HELLO
BY LOS ANGELES DILLON THE
CRITICAL HOUSING NEED TO THE
EIGHT RIGHT FOR THESE REASONS
MEMBERS SUPPORT ON THURSDAY AB
TWO THREE THREE THANK YOU YOUR
TODAY. THANK YOU SO. THANKS FOR
FROM HOLLY FROM ANY. FROM
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY. GOOD
MORNING MEDICARE NUMBER OF THE
POLICY MEETING AT DAY CARE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF HABITAT FOR
HUMANITY CALIFORNIA AND OR
FORTY MILLION VOLUNTEER
THROUGHOUT THE DAY. FORTY LATER
THE AS TEN DIFFERENT THE- JACK
HOWEVER MANY THAT THE BIG THE
QUESTION TOTAL HAVE BEEN
UTILIZED TO GET YOU OVER THEIR
APPLICABILITY PARTICULAR
PRODUCT INSIGHT AND IN MANY
CASES DIFFICULTY MEETING. YOU
ORDER VERY. COMPLEX AFTER THE
DOCTOR. RIGHT NOW LIKE MANY
OTHER HOW DEVELOPER THROUGHOUT
THE- I THINK EVENING.
CONSTRUCTION AFFORDABLE HOUSING
SIX THE COMPLEX PROCESSES TO
PROJECT. I THINK. EVEN OUR A
100% OF WHAT BUILDER AND WITH
INCREASING NUMBER OR IT
HOMEOWNERS PROJECT HABITAT HAS
MADE FINANCIAL. TO AVOID ABOUT.
OF PRODUCT THAT MIGHT BE
SUBJECT TO PRIVILEGED LEGAL
CHALLENGES UNDER THE GRASS THE
CHALLENGES ARE USUALLY BACKED
BY LOCAL WELL FUNDED ANTI
GROWTH COMMITTEE ACTIVISTS WHO
ARE IN OPPOSE ON THEY ACTUALLY
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. AND REALLY
STAGES OF THE PLANNING. FOR
THEM. A GREATER IS THE PROJECT
IN REDWOOD CITY CALIFORNIA
BECAME SUBJECT TO MORE YEAR LAW
TO. INCREASE THE TOTAL OF THE
PROJECT. FOR THE EIGHTEEN MONTH
DELAYED BECAUSE- AND ULTIMATELY.
IN ABOUT THAT WE THE TIME
NUMBER PLANNED AFFORDABLE UNITS
AND QUALIFIED THAT ARE ABLE
THIRD IN THE COMMUNITY. WE
BELIEVE THAT A LOT OF. TO AB
THREE THREE WHAT HAPPENED YOU
PEOPLE AND ASKING. EVEN TWENTY
THREE TWENTY THREE HELPED THAT
THEY HOUSING. AND CLIMATE
CRISIS I STATING THAT. THE
THINK THE QUESTION LEADING
OPTIONS AND MAKE IT EASY. ABOUT
YEAH YOU FOR THE THREE OF THEM
HAVE A HAVE VERY MANY
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR ITEM
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MUCH.
SHOULD IT LEADS THE NOW. AT THE
IT'S A IF IS THIS ANYONE CHAU
EVER TWENTY. ASSUMING NOT WILL
WE'LL GO LOOK AT THE VIDEO PER
SECOND. OKAY NOW. LET'S GO TO
THE PHONE LINES OUTSIDE
MODERATE IF YOU COULD YOU FOLKS
UP FOR THOSE WHO WANT TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT FOR THE BILL
ON THE PHONE. PORTS FOR THE
CURRENT BILL YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN HIT ZERO AT THIS TIME.
WE HAVE SIX ALREADY IN QUEUE.
WE'LL GO AHEAD AND START WITH
MY NUMBER FOUR NINE THAT'S FOUR
NINE ONE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
MEMBERS OF THE ALT RIGHT WITH
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS SUPPORT. THANK YOU
OVER THE LINE NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY EIGHT ONE
TWO EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS JUSTIN
HIGHER BEHALF OF THE SILICON
VALEY LEADERSHIP GROUP MORE
PROBLEMS FOR THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANKS NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY ONE ONE THREE ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
JAMIE MINOR ON BEHALF BRIDGE
HOUSING INTO THANK YOU. OVER
THE LINE NUMBER ONE HUNDRED
THIRTY TWO THAT'S ONE THREE TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MORNING
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE ADAM
RILEY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. MY NUMBER
ONE HUNDRED THIRTY FIVE ONE
THREE FIVE CAROLINE IS OPEN.
BUDGET BOB NAYLOR REPRESENTING
FEELS DEAD AND COMPANY A STRONG
SUPPORTER OF CALIFORNIA INDIAN
ORANGE COUNTY BUSINESS STRONG
SUPPORT. THIRTY SIX WHAT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MORNING CARE
NUMBERS THAT THE SNACK BAR IN
CALIFORNIA BY OTHERS HERE FOR
THE ASSOCIATION ENVIRONMENTAL
PROFESSIONALS IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. IN ADDITION WE HAVE FIVE
MORE THAT HAVE QUEUED UP A
LITTLE AYE NUMBER SIXTY FIVE
SIX FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING IF YOU HAVE IT ALL
ON BEHALF OF THE BAY AREA
COUNSEL AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
WILL I NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
FIVE ONE ZERO FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. CAN YOU HELP THE BAY AREA
HOUSING ADVOCACY COALITION. FOR
YOUR LITTLE LINE NUMBER THIRTY
NINE THREE NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MORNING BILL DEAL FOR OUR
AREA WE HAVE THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU A LITTLE
AYE NUMBER TWENTY FIVE TO FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. LINE TWENTY
FIVE CAN YOU CHECK YOUR LINE
FOR SELF MEANS WE'RE NOT
HEARING YOUR AUDIO. I'M SORRY
ALL MICHAEL LOPEZ YOU A LOCAL
ONE ONE FOUR I'M IN OPPOSITION
AND STAND WITH THE BUILDING
TRADES ARE AT THE CALL NOW.
RIGHT NOW OUR FIFTH- PERSONALLY
QUEUED UP IS DROPPED OFF
SUBSEQUENTLY ONCE AGAIN AS A
REMINDER IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT PRESS ONE. ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND NO ONE ELSE IS
GEARING UP IN SUPPORT AT THIS
TIME. OKAY LET'S GO TO
OPPOSITION WE'RE GOING TO HEAR
FROM ERIN. HEY NEWS HERE IN THE
GALLERY FROM THE- STATE
BUILDING CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL. THANK YOU GOOD MORNING
CENTER AT ON MEMBERS OF THE
SENATE ENVIRONMENT COMMITTEE.
HI MY NAME IS ERIN LEHANE AND
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF THE STATE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL FOR. AND EIGHT
THREE THREE. THIRD THIS IS A
SIGNIFICANTLY LESS ROBUST
STREAMLINING BILL BUT AFTER
PROCEEDING TO THE ASSEMBLY WAS
DRAMATICALLY AMENDED BY THE
AUTHORS. NIPIGON EXPANSION OF
EXISTING AND NEW SEQUEL
EXEMPTIONS WE APPRECIATE THE
EARLY AMENDMENTS REMOVING THE
ABILITY OF DGSE TO CLEAR SITES
FOR CONSTRUCTION WHICH WOULD
HAVE PUT OUR MEMBERS HEALTH AND
SAFETY AT RISK AND HAVE
ATTEMPTED TO WORK WITH STAFF
AND REACHED. THE MANAGEMENT TO
MAKE THIS BILL LAST. TO THE
COMMUNITIES OUR MEMBERS LIVE
AND WORK IN. BUT OUR CURRENT
CONCERNS REMAIN. THIS BILL
UNDER NORMAL CIRCUMSTANCES
WOULD HAVE LIKELY BEEN REFERRED
TO MULTIPLE COMMITTEES BUT IN
THESE COLD AT TIMES THERE IS
BUT ONE POLICY COMMITTEE THAT
WILL HEAR THIS BILL IN THIS
FORUM. MANY THIS BILL PURPORTS
TO BE A TERRIBLE HOUSING THUS
REQUIRING ATTENTION DURING
THESE EXTREME TIMES. BUT UPON
READING THIS BILL IT BECOMES
QUITE CLEAR THAT ALTHOUGH IT
PROVIDES FOR STREAMLINING OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IT ALSO
PROVIDES ACCEPTANCE FOR PROFIT
DEVELOPERS TO BUILD NOT
AFFORDABLE HOUSING COMMERCIAL
DEVELOPMENT AND EVEN THE
INDUSTRIAL DEVELOPMENT. TENS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS PER PROJECT
WILL BE SAVED BY USING SUCH A
PROCESS AND YET EVEN WITH THIS
HUGE GIVE TO DEVELOPERS ALL OF
OUR REQUESTS TO AND WORKER
PROTECTIONS INCLUDING
PREVAILING WAGE AND SKILLED AND
TRAINED WORKFORCE. HAVE LOWERED.
THIS IS TO PUT MILES TRAVELED
BUT THE DEFINITION OF LOW VMT
CONTINUES TO EVOLVE AND IS SO
VAGUE THAT THE MEETING AN
APPLICATION ARE UNCLEAR AT BEST
AND ALTHOUGH THIS BILL STATED
INTENT OF THE LOW BMT STANDARD
IS TO SPUR TRANSIT AREA DEVELOP.
MERRY MAPPING SHOWS ENTIRE
URBAN COMMUNITIES THAT COULD BE
DETERMINED TO BE LOVING ANTI A
YEAH NOT ALSO CONTAIN
PRODUCTIVITY TO TRANSIT. THIS
BILL JUST NEEDS SOME MORE WORK.
ON BEHALF OF THE BOARD FOR THE
BUILDING TRADES FOUR HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND MEMBERS AND
ESPECIALLY OUR SIXTY EIGHT
THOUSAND APPRENTICES STATE
WHILE. WE ASK YOU TO CONSIDER
HOLDING THIS BILL UNTIL THE
ISSUE SAID- IN OUR OPPOSITION
LETTER CAN BE FULLY CONSIDERED.
THANK YOU. YOU CAME OKAY LET'S
HEAR NOW FROM- I GUESS IT'S
STILL NOBODY IN TWENTY FORTY.
ASSUMING NOT YES AND AS NON
THERE LET'S GO TO LINES. HI
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND IF
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE A
VERY MANY PEOPLE IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME OVER. I'LL START WITH
LINE NUMBER TWENTY EIGHT IN
PROCEEDINGS THAT YOU TELL ME
THAT WE OF RUN OUT OF TIME WHAT
THE START LINE NUMBER TWENTY
EIGHT. ONE IS OVER. WHAT BETTER
DO WAY LOCAL OH NINE LOS
ANGELES I AND THE STATE ONLY
TRADE OUR THANK YOU. WE'RE
GOING TO OPEN A SIXTEEN ONE
ZERO IS GOOD MORE. SENATOR ALAN
AND THE REST OF YOU FOLKS ON
THE- COMMITTEE THIS IS ROBERT
SMITH. H. DISTRICT COUNCIL
SIXTEEN WITHOUT SKILLED AND
TRAINED AND PREVAILING WAGE.
HERE'S A BILL NEEDS WORK AND
WE'RE OPPOSING THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SEE TRAVELED A LOT NUMBER
FORTY ONE FOR ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME
IS STEVEN BOOKER IN THE
POLITICAL DIRECTOR AND
COMMUNITY LIAISON COMPARE
MEMBER FOR IBEW LOCAL. SIX
SEVENTEEN REPRESENTING OVER
SEVENTEEN HUNDRED. WE STAND
WITH BUILDING TRADES AND ALSO
OF THIS. ON WELL I NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED THIRTY FOUR ONE THREE
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MISTER
CARE MEMBER. CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION AND STANDING WITH
THE BUILDING TRADES IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. WE'LL GO
TO LINE NUMBER EIGHTEEN ONE
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING EVERYONE LOCAL TO FIFTY
STANFORD WE STRONGLY OPPOSE AB.
TWENTY THREE TWENTY THREE.
THANK YOU A LITTLE AYE NUMBER
THIRTY SIX THREE SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING A OUR
HEART BY THE DERBY SIX
SEVENTEEN. DEVELOPMENT
MEMBERSHIP WE OPPOSE AB TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU A LITTLE AYE NUMBER
THIRTY ONE THREE ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GENERAL MOTORS OF THE
COMMITTEE- THE ARTWORK STATE
SENATOR BRIAN DALLY THIS IS THE
INTERNET. IN THE NORTHEASTERN
CALIFORNIA BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL.
BEHALF OF OUR THOUSANDS OF
MEMBERS SPECIALLY ARE CURRENTLY
CALIFORNIA'S NORTHERN TOWN. I
RISING SOLIDARITY WITH THE
BUILDING TRADES. IN STRONG
OFTEN AB. TWENTY THREE TWENTY
IF YOU GO TO ONE NUMBER SEVEN
SIX SEVEN THIS JULY IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN AND-
HELLO COMMITTEE MEMBERS- MY
NAME IS TOMMY BOB I REPRESENT
IBEW LOCAL WORKERS LOCAL ELEVEN
IN ST LOUIS ON BEHALF OF OUR-
TWELVE. MEMBERS IT WAS SENT. WE
ARE STILL OPPOSE OF THE BEACH
THREE TWENTY THREE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WILL I NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND NINETEEN ONE ONE
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. IN
OPPOSITION UNTIL AMENDED TO
INCLUDE SKILLED AND TRAINED
WORKFORCE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
WILL I NUMBER THIRTY THREE
THREE THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THIS BROTHERHOOD OF ELECTRICAL
WORKERS LOCAL FORTY MAKING KERN
COUNTY WE STAND WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE BUILDING
TRADES IN OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY
THREE TWO THREE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OVER THE LINE NUMBER
ONE. TWO ONE ZERO TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD EVERYONE JOHN
DOUGHERTY INTERNATIONAL
BROTHERHOOD OF ELECTRICAL
WORKERS LOCAL SECTION SAN
FRANCISCO REPRESENTING THREE
THOUSAND MEMBERS. AND THEIR
FAMILIES- AND WE STAND OPPOSED.
UNLESS AMENDED. THANK YOU. OKAY
LINE NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND ONE
ONE ZERO ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING ONE ONE BALL OF
IRON WORKERS UNION LOCAL THREE
SEVENTY REPRESENTING TWENTY
FIVE HUNDRED NUMBERS ACROSS.
THE NORTH BAY AREA. IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
ALONGSIDE THE STATE BUILDING
TRADES. THANK YOU WITH A LINE
NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND FOUR ONE
ZERO FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING GRETCHEN ON BEHALF
OF IDW SIX NINE IN OUR THIRTY
FOUR HUNDRED MEMBERS ACROSS SAN
DIEGO AND IMPERIAL COUNTY.
STRONG WITH TWENTY BUILDINGS IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU RELY
NUMBER FORTY SIX FOUR SIX ZERO
ONE IS OVER. MEMBERS MY NAME IS
RICK SMILED AT THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA DESERT COUNSEL
WAIVERS. WE HAVE OVER THIRTY
THOUSAND PLUS MEMBERS IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA WE STAND
WITH THE BILLING TRADE IN
OPPOSITION OF AB. TWO THREE TWO
THREE THANK YOU. THANK YOU ALLY
NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND THREE
ZERO THREE YOUR LINE IS. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS AN ISSUE SELL
BUSINESS AGENT OF MOBILE SO
HEAT ACROSS INSULATOR WERE
SEVEN HUNDRED MEMBERS NORTH
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA. FONG
OPPOSITION AT TWENTY THREE
TWENTY THREE THANK. ALTHOUGH MY
NUMBER SEVENTY EIGHT SEVEN
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE
SEPARATE TICKET YOURSELF MUTE
YES THIS IS RON MILLER WITH THE
L. A. R. THE BUILDING TRADES ON
BEHALF OF THE HUNDRED FORTY
THOUSAND SKILLED AND TRAINED
MEN AND WOMEN THAT WORK HERE
EVERY DAY. ON THIS PLEASE THE
BILL. GET IT RIGHT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WILL AND TWENTY FOUR
TWO FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING. AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MY NAME IS GREG BASHAM I'M WITH
THE TEAMSTERS AND I STAND WITH
THE STATE BUILDING TRADES IN
OPPOSITION. TO WHAT THREE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU LITTLE
AYE NUMBER EIGHTY EIGHT EIGHT
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING. MY NAME IS FRED LIMON
ABOUT THE MEMBERS PHARMACIST IN
BETTER LOCAL UNION NUMBER THREE
FORTY THREE OF NOT. AND SOLANO
COUNTIES. IN THE STATE. STRONG
OPPOSITE ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
THREE TWENTY THREE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WILL GET A LINE
NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND TWENTY
SIX ONE TWO SIX YOUR PLANS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING. HELLO OPERATING
ENGINEERS LOCAL THREE. WE
OPPOSE THIS BILL. EMBEZZLEMENT
THANK YOU I NUMBER NINETY ZERO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. LINE NINETY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN THIS IS A
RATE OF ANTI- LOCAL THREE
NINETY EIGHT NUMBERS OF. THE
CLOSE TO. THE RESOLUTION. THANK
YOU OVER LINE NUMBER THIRTY
FIVE THREE FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YES IT'S FRUSTRATING THE
FACT. HM REPRESENTATIVE THE
INFLATORS AND ALLIED WORKERS
LOCAL SIXTEEN TO STAND BUILDING
TRADES STRONGLY AT OFFICE.
THANK YOU WILL I NUMBER EIGHTY
EIGHT ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
BUT THREE FORTY THREE THE STATE
BETTER NAPA'S COUNTY WE STAND
WITH THE BILL TRADE OF THIS
BILL. THANK YOU NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED TWENTY THREE TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS
MANAGED BY DPW FOUR FOUR ONE
ORANGE COUNTY AND WE'RE JOINING
THE STATE BUILDING TRADES IN
OPPOSITION YOU. NUMBER SIX
NINE. NINE IS OPEN. HI BRIAN
HOLD A PROBLEM INTERNATIONAL
BROTHERHOOD OF ELECTRICAL
WORKERS AND WE OPPOSE THIS BILL
AS WRITTEN. HELLO MY NAME
TWENTY ONE TO ONE YOUR LINE IS.
GOOD MORNING AGAIN THERE GOES
THE SECRETARY TREASURER LANE
LOCAL TO TWENTY WE OPPOSE- AB
BILL TWENTY THREE TWENTY THREE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU WILL GO TO
ANOTHER FIFTY NINE FIVE NINE
YOUR LINES OPEN. GOOD MORNING
EVERYONE MY NAME IS TRISTEN
CHAU VICE PRESIDENT LABOR'S
UNION THREE FIFTY THREE TO FOUR
AND WE HAVE OVER FIVE THOUSAND
AS WE SPEAK WITH THE STATE
BUILDING TREE. EIGHT THREE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU WILL I
NEVER SEVEN FIVE SEVEN YOU LOG
SO. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
MARK UP I. LOCAL FIVE NINE FIVE
COUNTY WE STAND WITH IT IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL THANK
YOU. NUMBER EIGHTY FOUR EIGHT
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ROB
STILL PER ON BEHALF OF THE
HIGHLY SKILLED AND TRAINED
WOMEN AND MEN AND METAL WORKERS
LOCAL ONE OF FOUR. WE FOR NINE
AND CAL FIFTY. WE MUST STRONGLY
THIS BILL AS IT FAILS TO
BALANCE THE NEEDS OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING THE NEEDS TO IMPROPER
STANDARD. YEAH THANK YOU. YOU
WILL GET A LINE NUMBER SIXTY
TWO SIX TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME I'M NOT
PRESIDENT OF OUR WORKERS LOCAL
ONE FIVE I'M DURING THE STATE
TRADE AND- BOB. THANK THANK YOU
WILL I NUMBER SIXTY SIX ZERO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. PONDELOK
FRAZIER OF HOME DON'T OR
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES. CLOSE THIS OUT BILL AB.
TWENTY THREE TWENTY THREE AM
TELEMANAGEMENT. CLUES SKILLED
AND TRAINED AND PREVAILING WAGE.
THANK YOU WILL GO TO LINE
NUMBER TWENTY SIX TWO SIX ZERO
AS OPEN. YES GOOD MORNING KAREN
WELCH- CONSTRUCTION TEAMSTER
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA LOCAL ONE
SIX SIX AND WE'RE JOINING THE
BUILDING TRADES IN THEIR
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. SEVEN
EIGHT SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
IT IS A FEELING IT HAD THE
REPRESENTATIVE. FIFTY TWO.
TRADE IN OPPOSITION TO AB
TWENTY THREE TWENTY THREE THANK
YOU. THANK BY NUMBER NINETY TWO
NINE TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
CLLR DAVIS OPERATING ENGINEERS
LOCAL TWELVE WE ALL WHO STAND
IN OPPOSITION OF THE BILL. IT
WOULD ALIGN NUMBER SEVENTY
SEVEN SEVEN SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING BOARD
MEMBERS MY NAME IS JOE BURNETT
I WORKERS LOCAL A LOCAL ONE
FIVE FIVE. JOIN THE STATE
BUILDING TRADE. AND OPPOSITION
OF AB TWENTY THREE TWENTY THREE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU WILL I
NUMBER EIGHTY TWO EIGHT TO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THIS IS CHRIS
BETTERMENT THE OPERATING
ENGINEERS LOCAL THREE-
POLITICAL DIRECTOR. AND ABOUT
LOCAL FREE OPPOSE. A MUSCLE
MONDAY. THANK YOU NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND SIXTEEN ONE ONE SIX
YOUR LINE IS UP. GOOD MORNING
THE REPRESENTATIVE FOR DISTRICT
COUNCIL SIXTEEN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND WE USE.
SUPPORTABILITY TRADE BILL POSES.
LOCAL THANK YOU. THANK YOU WHAT
A LINE NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
NINE ONE ZERO NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. WHAT ARE NINE CHECK YOUR
LINE FOR MUTE WE'RE HEARING
AUDIO. NO IDEAL FOR ONE ZERO
NINE WE WILL MOVE ALONG TO
LIGHT NUMBER SIXTY SIX SIX SIX
YOUR LINE IS. GOOD MORNING HERE.
I LOCAL ONE EIGHT ONE
ACCOUNTING AND WE ARE OPPOSE.
THANK YOU WILL GET A LOT NUMBER
ONE HUNDRED AND TWENTY ONE TWO
ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING. HERE'S BUILDING
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL AND
WE STAND WITH THE STATE
BUILDING IN OPPOSITION THE BABY.
TWENTY TWENTY THREE. THANK YOU
WITH A ONE FOR SEVENTEEN ONE
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THEY
WOULD. SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
BUILDING TRADES ON THIS BILL IT
OPPOSITE THANK YOU. A LINE OF
FIFTY EIGHT FIVE EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MORE MY NAME IS
VERY CAME OF THE HELP OF LOCAL
TO THIRTY PLUMBERS AND
PIPEFITTERS REPRESENTING
EIGHTEEN HUNDRED MEMBERS WE ARE
TO TAKE BUILDING IN THERE ARE.
THANK YOU WILL I NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND SEVEN ONE ZERO
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY
NAME IS NATALIE HALEY I'M
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE OVER
ONE THOUSAND MEN AND WOMEN OF
AIDID LOCAL FIVE FIVE ONE AND
OUR BUSINESS MANAGER JOHN AT.
WE STATE. COUNCIL OPPOSITION TO
A TWO THREE TWO THREE. WE
BELIEVE ONLY FOR LABOR
PROTECTION AND NOT FACE OR AT.
ADDRESS THE HEALTH CRISIS AND
HELP. THANK YOU. THANK YOU WILL
AND THEN TWELVE ONE TWO MINUTE
OVER. THE CALIFORNIA STATE
COUNCIL. WE THE THAT WERE NAY
TAKEN BY THE AUTHOR HOWEVER WE
MUSTN'T THE CAR VERSION THE
BILL THEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU
WILL ONE OF TWENTY SEVEN SEVEN.
SO. MORNING MR SHERIDAN DURABLE
MEMBERS OF MY AGE TO GET BACK
OR THIRD AND TODAY I WAS OF
BEHALF O THESE MODERATES CRUZ
BUILDING AGAINST. CAL I AS WELL
AS MODERN. AND SANTA CRUZ
BOMBERS AND SPEAKER LOCAL SIXTY
AND WE'RE- THE STATE THOUGH
TRADE AND ARE OFTEN TO THIS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU INDUSTRY
SENATE FLORIDA ME SIXTEEN STILL
PENDING Q. WE WILL GO TO LINE
NUMBER SEVENTY NINE SEVEN NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. A NEW SPENDING CRIME
WITH A LADY SEVEN DISTRICT
COUNCIL OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU A LITTLE AYE
NUMBER FIFTY FOUR FIVE FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. ONE MOMENT WHEN
IT IS READY LLOYD FROM HEAT AND
FROST INSULATORS LOCAL BIKE LOS
ANGELES AND WE ARE JOINED AS
STATE BUILDING TRADES UNDER ALL
OPPOSITION UP AB TWENTY TWENTY.
TWENTY TWENTY THREE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ONE OF NINETY EIGHT
NINE EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING MANY SHOPPING
REPRESENTED THOUSAND CLIMBERS
AND THEIR FAMILIES IN SANTO
COUNTY AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE
AB TWO THREE TWO THREE THANK
YOU. OVERALL I NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY SEVEN ONE
THREE SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MORE MORE LABOR LOCAL POINT
FOUR AND WE ALSO WITH THE STATE
BILL TRADES IN OPPOSITE OF THE
BILL AND AMENDED. THANK YOU
WITH A LINE OF FIFTY TWO FOR
TWO YOUR LINE OPEN. MORNING MY
NAME IS RJ FOR YOU A LOCAL
THIRTY EIGHT PLUMBERS AND
PIPEFITTERS SAN FRANCISCO WE
ARE STANDING WITH THE STATE
BUILDING CONSTRUCT REYES
COUNCIL TO. AB TWO THREE. THANK
YOU YEAH. THANK YOU WILL I
NUMBER ONE HUNDRED ELEVEN
TRIPLE ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING. CALIFORNIA THE
CRISIS JOINT HELPFUL FRTY YOU
WE FINALLY BEGIN WITH THE
BUILDING IN OPPOSITION TO THE
GRAHAM BILL THREE TWENTY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU THIRTY SEVEN
RESEARCH YOUR LINE IS A- GOOD
MORNING THIS IS JANE FOSTER
WOULD PLUMBERS PIPEFITTERS
LOCAL FOR VENTURA STAND WITH
THE BUILDING TRADES IN STRONG
OPPOSITION OF AB. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU BUT A LINE NUMBER
SIXTY THREE SIX THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS JOHN HENRY LOPEZ I'M WITH
THE U. A LOCAL TWO FOUR SIX
ARMORS AND PIPEFITTERS
REPRESENTING A NUMBER THERE
UNTIL OUR KINGS COUNTY. AND WE
ARE JOINING THE STATE BUILDING
TRADE AND THERE'S IN THERE
OPPOSITION AB THREE TWENTY
THREE THANK. THANK YOU NUMBER
FORTY EIGHT FOUR EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS A- HI ALAN COMMITTEE
MEMBER MY NAME MARCO I'M ONE OF
MORE THAN FOURTEEN HUNDRED
MEMBERS OF THE PLUMBERS AND
PIPEFITTERS LOCAL OR SIX SEVEN.
TONY WE JOIN THE- POSING AB
TWENTY TWENTY THREE AND TOLLS
AMENDED TO INCLUDE STANDARDS
AND REQUIRED TO PAY
CONSTRUCTION WORKERS FAIRLY AND
REQUIRE EMPLOYMENT SKILLS AND
WORKFORCE I RESPECTFULLY URGE
YOU TO VOTE ON THE BILL THANK
YOU. THANKS SIX IN TOTAL ONE
NUMBER FOR ONE FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. OVER ONE THOUSAND MEMBERS
AND THEIR FAMILIES OF LOCAL
THREE NINETY EIGHT- IN
OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY THREE
TWENTY THREE UNLESS IT'S
AMENDED THANK YOU. THANK YOU
OVER THE LINE NUMBER SEVENTY
FOUR SEVEN FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YES SIR HI GOOD MORNING
SCHERING COMMITTEE AND THOSE
WHO ARE LISTENING MY NAME'S
JOHN MORALIS I'M A VICE
PRESIDENT OF TEAMSTERS LOCAL
SEVEN REPRESENTS CURRENT COUNTY
WE STAND IN THE STATE BUILDING
TREE. BOTH THE BILL THANK YOU
JUST BE. THANK YOU WILL NUMBER
FIFTY ONE FIVE ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING THIS IS JUST
THE SAME OF THE OPERATING
ENGINEERS LOCAL THREE. AND WE
ARE JOINING THE STATE BUILDING
TRADES IN THEIR OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU LITTLE ONE
NUMBER THIRTY EIGHT THREE EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
CRAIG HARLEM IN PREVENT THE
INTERNATIONAL UNION OF ELEVATOR
CONSTRUCTORS LOCAL EIGHT. CAN
BE SEEN IN OPPOSITION WITH THE
STATE BUILDING TRADES AB TWENTY
THREE TWENTY THREE. THANK YOU A
LINE NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
FORTY THREE THAT'S ONE FOUR
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SHARE
MY NAME IS SEAN SPAULDING HI.
THE KERN INYO AND MONO. RACIAL
WE STAND WITH THE STATE THE
RATINGS TRADE COUNCIL IN STRONG.
TO AB TWENTY THREE TWENTY THREE
LESSONS AND- THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ARE LESS WANTING TO AT THIS
TIME IS ONE ONE AND FIVE THAT'S
WHY FOUR FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YEAH MY NAME'S MARTIN RODRIGUEZ
BUSINESS AGENT I WORK WITH
LOCAL FOR THIRTY THREE. WE
OPPOSE THIS BILL ALONG WITH TRI
COUNTY. BUILDING CONSTRUCTION
TRADES THANK YOU. AT THIS TIME
WE HAVE EXHAUSTED THE Q. WOULD
YOU LIKE ME TO REPRINT. SURE IF
YOU HAVE ANY SENSE THERE MAY BE
MORE PEOPLE. THANK WHAT IS YOUR
OPPOSITION IS BILL AND WOULD
LIKE TO HAVE YOUR VOICE HEARD
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN IF ZERO
AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE ONE
THAT'S JUST CHEWED UP WE'RE
GOING TO PROVIDE THEM THEIR
LINE NUMBER AND SO THAT THEY
MAY BE HEARD. RANGEL LINE
NUMBER FORTY TWO THAT'S FOR TO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THIS IS
RACHEL SHOEMAKER I NEED TO BE
LOCAL TRIO TO WE REPRESENT OVER
FOURTEEN HUNDRED MEMBERS AND
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY. AND WE ARE.
TRADE OPPOSITION BILL THANK YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU SO MUCH
EVERYBODY. FOR YOUR ARE FOR THE
TESTIMONY I MEAN TO BE HONEST
WITH YOU I THIS. THIS LONG LIST
OF TESTIMONY WAS A BIT OF A
SURPRISE TO ME AND WE GOT A
LETTER BUT I DON'T THINK WE GOT
A SINGLE CALL FROM- TO THE
COMMITTEE FROM. THE TRADES BUT-
WE APPRECIATE IT ALL TURNS
REYES IN FACT LET ME GIVE
AUTHORED THE OPPORTUNITY IF
SHE'D LIKE TO ANSWER SOME OF
THE CONCERNS THAT WERE RAISED
ON THE- ON THE CALLS. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK TO THE CALLS I WILL SAY
IT IS A BIT DISCOURAGING FOR ME
TO HEAR. LONG LIST OF
OPPOSITION GIVEN. THAT WE HAVE
HAD THESE AMENDMENTS IN PRINT
SINCE JULY FIRST. WE SHARED
THEM WITH THE TRADE IN MAY
ELEVENTH. THEY WERE FORMALLY A
SUPPORT POSITION ON THE BILL
AND WE ONLY FOUND OUT LATE LAST
WEEK THAT THEY WERE NOW. AND
POST PETITION. I DON'T HAVE TO
SEE AMENDMENTS TO THE WE GET M.
A CONSIDERABLE AMENDMENTS WE
WERE NOT GIVEN ANY AMENDMENTS.
SO IT'S A LITTLE BIT UNCLEAR TO
US EXACTLY WHAT THEY ARE
LOOKING FOR WHEN THEY SAY THEY
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED. BUT I
WILL SAY THIS. JUST TO CLARIFY
THAT THIS BILL. DOES NOT ADD
ANY NEW EXEMPTIONS TO SEQUOIA.
WHAT IT DOES IS IT CLARIFIES N.
STREET THEY DON'T EXPAND THE
EXAM BUT ONLY BECAUSE- WE'VE
BUT THOSE EXACT. WORKING ALWAYS
FOR THE PURPOSE FOR WHICH THEY
WERE INTENDED. THREE TO CLARIFY
THAT IF BUILDING. HOUSING FOR.
IN URBAN AND BY SO YOU'RE-
SPRAWL YOU REDUCING VEHICLE
MILES TRAVELED YOUR NEW BECAUSE
YOUR YOUR JOBS ARE TRANSIT YOU
SHOULD BE ABLE TO USE THE
EXISTING SEPARATE EXEMPTION.
WHAT THE TRADES ARE ASKING FOR
IS THAT ALL OF THOSE PROJECTS
THAT ARE CURRENTLY USING THOSE
EXEMPTIONS NOW HAVE TO HAVE
PROJECT LABOR AGREEMENTS. A NEW
SKILL AND THE SKILLED WORKFORCE
WHAT THAT MEANS IS THAT. THE
PERSON WHO RIGHT NOW IS
BUILDING A FOUR PLEX WITH THEIR
OWN MONEY ON PRIVATE PROPERTY
NEAR TRANSIT. WHICH WE DOES NOT
HAVE ENTER INTO THAT KIND OF
AGREE WOULD FOR FURTHER TO. USE
EXEMPTION. BUT ANY PROJECT THAT
USING THOSE CURRENT EXEMPTIONS.
AT RIGHT NOW FOR FREE FROM
HAVING TO USE. THAT THAT A
SKILLED WORKFORCE BECAUSE OF
THEIR SIZE BECAUSE THEY DON'T
USE ANY PUBLIC MONEY FOR
WHATEVER REASON WOULD NO LNGER
BE ABLE TO USE AN EXEMPTION
THAT THEY COULD USE RIGHT NOW
OR YESTERDAY OR LAST YEAR. SO
THIS IS A VAST EXPANSION OF
THAT REQUIRE. THERE'S NOTHING
THAT STOPS THE BUILDING TRADES
FROM THE GLACIATION. THOSE
TERMS WITH DEVELOPERS AND THEY
FREQUENTLY DO THAT IN THESE
AREAS THERE'S NOTHING IN THIS
BILL THAT RULES ANY OF THOSE
PROTECTIONS FACT. SO I DON'T
UNDERSTAND THE ARGUMENT ABOUT
HOW THIS ROLLS WORKER
PROTECTIONS BACK. THIS IS
MERELY WORKING WITH CURRENT
EXEMPTIONS IN THE LAW. SO WE
ARE OF COURSE MORE THAN HAPPY
TO CONTINUE TO HAVE DISCUSSIONS
WITH THE TRADE WE SEE THEM AS
PARTNERS ON OUR LEGISLATION WE
SEE THEM AS ALLIES. TURNED TO
PROTECTING WORKERS. PROTECTING
THE ECONOMY IN OUR AREA. BUT
WE- BOB IN TILL WE SEE THE
AMENDMENTS FROM THEM IT'S VERY
HARD FOR US TO BE ABLE TO
RESPOND TO THIS OPPOSITION. SO
I WOULD ASK THE COMMITTEE FOR
THE COURTESY OF ALLOWING THIS
BILL TO MOVE FORWARD AND I
WOULD HAVE TO TRADE TO PLEASE
SIT DOWN WITH US. WELL IN
ADVANCE OF OUR NEXT HEARING AND
GIVE US THE OPPORTUNITY. TO
WORK WITH YOU. TO ADDRESS ANY
CONCERNS THAT YOU MIGHT HAVE.
NOW IN TERMS OF THEIR ISSUE
THEY BROUGHT UP A ABOUT
INDUSTRIAL DEVELOPMENT AND
COMMERCIAL I WANT TO CLARIFY
THIS BILL DOES NOT. ADD
EXEMPTIONS FOR INDUSTRIAL USES
OR COMMERCIAL USES. THE BILL
MENTIONS THE WORD COMMERCIAL
ONLY TO SPECIFY THE AREA IN
WHICH HOUSING IS TO BE BUILT IN
COMMERCIAL AREAS SO I DO WANT
TO CLARIFY THAT FOR THE RECORD.
AND AGAIN WE'RE VERY HAPPY TO
CONTINUE TO THIS IS TO BE
DISCUSSED WITH THE TRADE WE DID
ADD THEIR AMENDMENTS. GOING
INTO THE LAST COMMITTEE THE
AND- INVITE THEM TO COME IN AND
SIT DOWN WITH MYSELF AND MY
STAFF TO CONTINUE THE
DISCUSSION. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR THANK YOU THANK YOU-
MADISON NUMBER ONE WE NOW GO TO
CENTER WILL CASKEY RESEARCHER I
AYE HAS. WITH REGARD TO
ENVIRONMENTAL CONCERNS ONE OF
THE STAFF. TALKS ON PAGE ABOUT
YOU KNOW SB THIRTY FIVE WHICH
CREATED A LOT OF. MNY MORE
EXEMPTIONS ON AFFORDABLE
HOUSING HAS A SUNSET DATE AND
THAT WAS NOT INCLUDED IN THE-
IN THE RECOMMENDED AMENDMENTS
BY THE COMMITTEE AND I WAS
WONDERING- IF I CAN GET THE
AUTHORS- TAKE ON THAT AND THE
REASON THAT I HAVE IS CLOSE TO
PAGE ELEVEN OF THE STAFF REPORT
AND WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THESE
LOW VEHICLE STANDS- TRAVEL BAN.
YEAH I THINK I TOOK A STEP BACK
WHEN I SAW THIS THEY REALIZE.
CALIFORNIANS DRIVE OF THE LOAD
OF MILES EVERY YEAR I MEAN WE
ARE YOU KNOW IT'S NOT UNCOMMON
FOR SOMEBODY TO BE TRAVELING
TWO HUNDRED MILES TO AND FROM
WORK. SO 85% OR TWO ONE AND
FIVE IS A RATHER LARGE AMOUNT
OF MONEY OUR LARGE AMOUNT OF
MILES WE'RE TALKING ABOUT FIRE
MENTAL CONCERNS CONCERNS SO.
THE STATE MAP POOL IS BEING
WERE ON BUT I DON'T KNOW I'M
CONCERNED WITH HAVING. THE IS
CAN A MEMBER ON THE EIGHTY. I
DON'T KNOW IF THE 85% IS THE
MAGIC EXEMPTION LEVEL
PARTICULARLY WITH. THE FACT
THAT THIS THIS. MODIFICATION OF
THE EXEMPTION OF VOLVO AGREE
WITH THAT LANGUAGE BECAUSE ON
FOREVER NEVER AND IT DOESN'T.
ALLOW THE TRIGGER TO COME TO
THIS. COMMITTEE FOR REVIEW SO
THAT'S MY- CAN THE AUTHOR. DO
YOU LIKE TO SPEAK TO THE
CONCERN OF THE CENTER
ABSOLUTELY THE SENATOR AND I
HAVE SPOKEN ABOUT THIS AND WE
SHARE THE SAME GOALS WITH
MAKING SURE THAT THESE PROJECTS
DO NOT ENCOURAGE SPRAWL BUT
THEY DON'T ENCOURAGE MORE
DRIVING THAT THEY DO THE
OPPOSITE WE ARE MORE THAN TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
COMMITTEE. AND WITH THE-
THEY'RE INTENDED TO DO SO WE-
HAVE AMPLE OPPORTUNITY AS WE
MOVE FORWARD WHETHER IN
APPROPRIATIONS ARE ON THE
FLOOR. TO MAKE FURTHER
REFINEMENTS OF THAT PORTION OF
THE BILL. IN IN THE OTHER. I
MEAN I'D LIKE TO STEP
AMENDMENTS ON DEFINING THE AREA
OF TRAVEL I AGAIN. WE TEN YEARS
AGO WE WOULD NEVER OF THOUGHT
THAT PEOPLE YOU KNOW DRIVING
FROM THE INLAND EMPIRE DOWN TO
THE WEST SIDE OF LA WOULD BE.
ONE NORMAL THING TO DO OR DO WE
HAVE SO MANY PEOPLE DOING IT
WAS SORT OF ALL A ONE OFF AND-
I. I THINK THAT'S. SIR WE LOOK
AT THE METROPOL AREA. WHAT IS
NOT FOR THE- ASCENTIAL. MAY BE
DIFFERENT OR MAYBE THE SAME AS
THE NORTHERN CALIFORNIA AND I'M
I'M- I'D LIKE TO HAVE SOME
INCENTIVE FOR PEOPLE TO TRAVEL
LESSEN THEIR CARS IN A-
SIGNIFICANT WAY HELLO. I WAS IN
PLANNING TO. THE TO VOTE ON THE
BILL I'VE HAD SOME CONCERN-
CONVERSATIONS WITH OUR- OUR
COLLEAGUE- MYSKINA WHO'S NOT
HERE BECAUSE OF THE COBIT
CHALLENGES ND SHE IS A
SUPPORTER OF- AB TWENTY THREE
TWENTY THREE SO. WITH THAT
CAVIAR THAT TIME WILL CONTINUE
TO LOOK AT THIS I WILL. MOVED
BILL FOR PURPOSES OF THIS
HEARING TODAY MR. THANK YOU
SENATOR. OTHER QUESTIONS
THOUGHTS DISCUSSION. I STILL
DON'T HAVE ANY EVIDENCE THAT
WE'VE BEEN JOINT ELECTRONICALLY
BY OUR COLLEAGUES BUT AND- YES.
SENATE STERN'S PROBABLY STILL
NEGOTIATORS BILLS- LET'S- LET'S
IF THE BILL'S BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR CASKEY. WE WILL CALL
THE ROLL AND THEN HOLD IT OPEN
FOR OTHER MEMBERS TO ADD. SO
CONSULT PLEASE. CALL THE ROLL
AND AB TWENTY THREE TWENTY
THREE ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AB
TWENTY THREE TWENTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. ALLEN NOW I DALY. BY
DALY I HILL SKINNER STERN WHITE
HOUSE STATE BY MY COUNTY HIGH.
OKAY WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN
THAT WAS- DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
SEND APPROPRIATIONS. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FRIEDMAN HAS ANOTHER
BILL TO PRESENT THIS IS AB
THIRTY TWO SEVENTY NINE ITEM
ELEVEN. ALSO RELATED TO SYKORA.
I YOU MAY PROCEED MARIE THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AB TWENTY
THIRTY TWO SEVEN NINE ATTENDED
TO ADDRESS COMMON DELAYS
LITIGATION OVER SEE WHAT
OPTIONS. TO PROMOTE SWIFTER AND
MORE EFFICIENT RESOLUTIONS OF
LAWSUITS REGARDING ALL PROJECTS.
HOW DO WE KNOW THERE ARE COMMON
DELAYS. AND THAT THE CURRENT
PROCEDURES TO EXPEDITE SEQUEL
OR AN ADEQUATE. EVERY YEAR
DOZENS OF BILLS ARE INTRODUCED
TO GIVE SPECIAL CONSIDERATION
TO FAVORED PROJECTS. WEATHER
SPORTS STADIUMS OR OTHER LARGE
PROJECTS WE HEAR FROM ADVOCATE
SAID WE NEED TO PASS SPECIFIC
LEGISLATION TO TARGET THOSE
PROJECTS BECAUSE OTHERWISE
THEY'LL GET CAUGHT UP. IN THE
LAWSUIT. RIGHT IN OUR WOULD
LIMITED SESSION THERE ARE SO
BILL. THAT CREATE HARD NINE
MONTH DEADLINE TO RESOLUTIONS
OF SECRET CASES INCLUDING
APPEALS. SINCE TWO THOUSAND
ELEVEN WE SEE NEARLY FIFTY SUCH
BILLS NOT TO MENTION SCORES A
BILL TO CREATE EXEMPTIONS FAVOR
PROJECTS. THE PREMISE OF ALL
THESE BILLS IS A FIGURE
JUDICIALYOU IN PARTICULAR IS
AN UNREASONABLE BURDEN CREATING
RISK AND DELAYED IT KILLS
PROJECTS. ISN'T THAT HAVE NOT.
I DON'T PROTECTION. THE PREMISE
OF THIS BILL IS A COMMON BELIEF
IN CIVIL LITIGATION SHOULD BE
ADDRESSED ACROSS THE BOARD FOR
ALL PROJECTS NOT JUST A
SPECIFIC VIEW FOR THAT YOU
DON'T HAVE TO BE A MULTIBILLION
CREATING A HUGE PROJECT TO BUY.
IT SHOULD BE EXPEDITED IN A WAY
THAT RESPECTS THE COURT'S. AND
DOESN'T JUST JAMMED UP WITH
ARBITRARY DEADLINE PARTICULARLY
WHEN THEIR RESOURCES ARE SPREAD
SO THIN. THE PRIOR VERSION OF
THIS BILL PRESS SEVEN I
APPRECIATE THE PATIENCE OF THE
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE WORK
TO CONTROVERSIES AND ADDRESS
CONCERNS FROM ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE COMMUNITIES FROM HER
AND OTHER STAKEHOLDERS. I THINK
THAT THIS BILL. MORE MODEST BUT
ALSO A VERY MEANINGFUL REFORM.
AS AMENDED THE BILL ADDRESSES
PREPARATION FOR THE RATE OF
ROCK. UNDER THE PROCESS BUTTE
FOOT DRAGGING AND GUESTS WHEN
SHIPPING ALL SIDES CAN ADD
MONTHS AT THE VERY BEGINNING TO
LITIGATION PROCESS THE BILL
GIVES LEADING AGENCIES THE
ABILITY TO RETAIN CONTROL OVER
PREPARATION OF THE RECORDS.
PROVIDED THAT THEY OFF. TO TWO
PETITIONERS. THIS BILL CREATE
TO THE SIX PROCESS STILL. A
ROBUST AND- PROTECTION BUT
PEOPLE WERE DESIGNED FOR.
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT BY PHONE
OR ADAM RIGGLE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
AND THE TO KEEP TABS CARRETTO
WITH NRDC AT RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE. AND I
MIGHT JUST SET UP THE INVER
COMMUNITY AND THE CHAMBER
SUPPORTING THE SAME VOTE. THIS
MOMENT THAT WE SHOULD ALL FAVOR.
THANK YOU. OKAY THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LET'S START
WITH YOU ADAM I THINK YOU'RE ON
THE PHONE LINE. MORNING
COMMITTEE ADAM RIGHTLY ON THE.
SO I COULD COME IN THEN YOU
BETTER LEARN. HE DID TO MAKE
MAKE SURE TO SPEAK CLEARLY ON
ACT YEAH. YEAH FEEDBACK I THINK
I'M ONE OF THEM I NEEDED THAT
OKAY SORRY ABOUT THAT GOOD
MORNING JEREMY COMMITTEE OUT
RIGHTLY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
IN SUPPORT. I WANNA HOLD TO
BEGIN BY THANKING. YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND YOU COMMITTEE STAFFER
ALL OUR WORK EIGHTEEN AND THE
VARIOUS STAKEHOLDERS- ADDING
THAT HARD WORK IS- FLOODED IN-
THE AMOUNT OF SUPPORT FOR THE
BILL AND THE FACT THAT- TO THE-
POINT. ET AND THE- BURKE. ARE
TESTIFYING BEFORE TODAY. I'M
NOT MAN EIGHTY THREE TO. NINE
PROVIDE. MENTAL BUT NEED FOR TO
THE- I'LL BE VERY CLEAR THE
BILL PRESERVES ALL OF PEOPLE
REVISED ENVIRONMENTAL. AND THE
BILL FOCUSED SOLELY ON
IMPROVING THE EFFICIENCY OF THE
LITIGATION PROCESS UNDER SPEAK
WELL. IN PREPARATION OF THE
ADMINISTRATIVE RECORD WHICH
SERVES AS THE ENTIRE UNIVERSE
OF DOCUMENTS AND EVIDENCE
BEFORE COURT PEOPLE LITIGATION.
IT HORRIFICALLY KIND CONSUMING
AND DEDUCTIBLE THE LEGAL
ARGUMENT THAT LEAD TO
UNNECESSARY DELAYS. THAT WILL
HINDER- THE REVOLUTION IN THE
BAR MENTAL ISSUES PERTAINING TO
LAND. USE PROJECTS CALIFORNIA.
BILL ADDRESSES COMMON PROBLEM
BY ROBERT PROCEDURES UNDER. THE
AUTHORIZE A LEADING DID ON THE
RESPONSE. ADMINISTRATIVE RECORD
SO LONG AS THE LEAD AGENCY
AGREED TO WAIVE ALL COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE PREPARATION
AND THAT NOTABLE CHANGE- REALLY
PRESERVES AND IF NOT SHE'LL
ANNIE KITCHENER'S WANTED TO
CHALLENGE. BUT WE IT THE FAIR
BALLOT AND READ PRO. SO IN
OTHER WORDS IT LEADING THE
OPERA CARE THAT ADMINISTRATIVE
RECORD UNDER SEQUEL OVER THE
PETITIONERS ELECTION TO DO SO
THE LEAD AGENCY CANNOT SEEK
REIMBURSEMENT FOR PROVISIONS
FOR THE COST TO REPAIR IT.
LEADING A GROUP. PROSECUTORS
THE GOAL THAT CAL SHOULD SHARE
BECAUSE THAT READ THE OF THE
ISSUES HELP BRING CAL MUCH MORE
NEEDED HOUSING AT LOWER COST
AND THE BILL WILL BE SO WITHOUT
COMPROMISING ANY OF THAT
STATUTE OBJECTIVE. BERMAN WE
THE BILL. A QUESTION THANK
THANK YOU I LET'S GO TO THE KID
AND NOW. THE MORNING CHAMBERS
NIKITA CROWDED WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL I'M
ENERGY PEACEFULLY FOR THE PARTY
LEADERS TO SEVENTY NINE THE
MOST RECENT AMENDMENTS HELP
GROUP ACCESS TO JUSTICE FOR THE
COMMUNITIES THAT NEED IT THE
MOST. AND WE LIKE TO THINK THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND HER STAFF
AND MANY OTHER EXCELLENT WORK
ON THE LAST SEVERAL WEEKS THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE
TO. THANK YOU THANK. EARN THREE.
IT'S THE NOW BEEN FOR ANYONE TO
FORTY. STILL NO ANSWER. OKAY
LET'S GO TO OUR THE PHONE LINES
WE HAVE. IF CHRIS. CHRIS WHO I
HEARD ON A- THE MORNING. GOOD
JOB. THANK YOU WOULD YOU YOU
WERE YOU WERE AT ALL THE BILL'S
YES GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS CHRIS MY KAYLEE ON
BEHALF OF HUMBLE AND MENDOCINO
REDWOOD COMPANIES IN SUPPORT OF
TH THANK YOU. OKAY THANK YOU
CHRIS. YOU WERE MORE PROLIX ON
THE RADIO. LET'S GO NOW TO THE
PHONE LINES. C. FOLKS WANT TO
TRANSPORT. ALLIANCE IF YOU WISH
TO SUPPORT THIS BILL YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME TO HAVE YOUR VOICE HEARD
THAT'S WHAT THEN IS ZERO. WE
HAVE. ABOUT A DOZEN IN Q. WILL
START REPLY NUMBER ONE HUNDRED
AND TWENTY NINE ONE TWO NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THIS
IS KATHY DUVA TELE WITH
METROPOLITAN WATER DISTRICT OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND WE ARE
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU WILL GO
TO LINE NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
FORTY SEVEN THAT'S ONE FOUR
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE SOVIET
POLICE TO SHOP ON BEHALF. VIDEO
LOS ANGELES MAYOR ERIC GARCETTI
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RELY NUMBER FORTY
NINE FOUR NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. I DIDN'T LIKE I PREFER
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
WILL GET A LINE NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND FORTY EIGHT
DEADLINE ONE FORTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS MORE RED TOP ON BEHALF
OF ORANGE COUNTY BUSINESS
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
LITTLE AND OVER ONE HUNDRED
FORTY NINE IT'S ONE FOUR NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OKAY LOOK
AT THE- CRANK CALLING ON BEHALF
OF SILICON VALLEY AT HOME. AND
CALIFORNIA GANDHI IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
LITTLE I NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY ONE FIVE ZERO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
JUSTIN HIGHER ON BEHALF OF THE
SILICON VALLEY LEADERSHIP GROUP
WE'RE PROUD TO SUPPORT THE BILL
THANK YOU. NUMBER ONE HUNDRED
AND THIRTY EIGHT ONE THREE
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I
LATER MEETING WITH WHITE HOUSE
PUBLIC AFFAIRS ON BEHALF OF
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY CALIFORNIA
AND THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA.
RESEARCH ASSOCIATION ON THE
COURT THANK YOU. THANK YOU OVER
THE INE NUMBER SIXTY FIVE AT
SIX FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
AT LEAST YOUR VISUAL ON BEHALF
OF THE BAY AREA COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
LITTLE AND OVER ONE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY ONE THREE ZERO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS CHELSEA
TO I'M WITH THE CENTER ON RACE
POVERTY THE ENVIRONMENT- WE'RE
PLEASED TO HAVE REMOVED OUR
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL LET IT
SHOULD BE THINKING MEN AND- I
JUST WANTED TO TALK REGION IN
THE- REMEMBER FRIEDMAN. A
CHALLENGE WELL AS YOUR- OR
DRESS YOUR CONCERNS. AND THOSE
OF OTHER GROUPS- WE APPRECIATE
YOUR PATIENCE AS WE CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH OTHER GROUPS DURING
THAT THEIR OPPOSITION THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. NUMBER THIRTY NINE
THREE NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING RUBIO FERRARI ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA BUILDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION SUPPORT.
THANK YOU A LITTLE AND OVER ONE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY ONE ONE FIVE
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THIS IS
JAMIE BELL ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA NATIVE PLANT SOCIETY
ALSO WANTED TO ECHO THE
COMMENTS THINKING THE MEMBER
FOR THE AMENDMENT AND THE BOYS
ARE. DIFFERENT IT'S ALL OF THE
MENACING. THANK YOU A LITTLE
LINE ONE HUNDRED AND FOR ONE
ZERO ZERO IS OPEN. ONE ZERO
FIVE CAN YOU CHECK YOUR LINE
FOR SELF MEANS WE'RE HEARING
AUDIO. AS REARING NO BODY OF
NUMBER ONE ZERO FIVE WILL GO TO
OUR FINAL LINE THAT IS Q.
CURRENTLY WHICH IS LIKE ONE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY TWO FIVE TWO
THE LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
SHARE MEMBERS. ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WATER
AGENCIES IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU LOOKS LIKE
ONE NUMBER ONE OH FIVE HIS
REPUTE WE'LL SEE IF WE CAN GET
AUDIO NOW ONE ONE ZERO FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HOW MANY TV
PETERSON ON BEHALF OF THE BAY
AREA HEALTH. I THINK.
POLITICIAN WORK. THANK YOU ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU'D LIKE TO VOICE
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME TO PLACE YOURSELF IN THE
QUEUE AND RECEIVE A LINE NUMBER.
SHE. AND THERE IS NOBODY
QUEUEING UP AT THIS TIME PLEASE
CONTINUE OKAY THANK YOU SO MUCH
OUR- MODERATOR OKAY LET'S NOW
GO THIS YEAR IF ANYONE. WANTS
TO VOICE OPPOSITION I DON'T
BELIEVE WE HAVE ANY LEAD
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION BUT
CERTAINLY IF I'M MISTAKEN- YOU
KNOW AND LOVE TO HEAR ABOUT
THAT- AND BELIEVES IN ONE ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. STILL AT
MODERATORS ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINES ELECTED TO VOICE CONCERNS
ARE OPPOSITION. TO AB THIRTY
TWO SEVEN NINE. IF YOU'D LIKE
TO VOICE CONCERNS ARE
OPPOSITION TO THE CURRENT BILL
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME TO PLACE YOURSELF
INTO THE QUEUE. OKAY DOES NOT
APPEAR ANYONE IS DOING UP AT
THIS TIME. OKAY THANK YOU. YOU
KNOW TO FROM. JUST FOR FOLKS TO
KNOW THERE WERE CERTAINLY AND
THERE ARE. GROUPS THAT WERE
LISTED IN OPPOSITION IN THE
ANALYSIS BUT AS WE DISCUSSED
SOME SIGNIFICANT AMENDMENTS
HAVE BEEN TAKEN. BY THE AUTHOR-
WORKING WITH US. UNTIL A NUMBER
OF A LOT OF THEM HAVE DROPPED
THEIR OPPOSITION- BUT OF COURSE
YOU KNOW WE WENT TO WE GET A-
LETTER WE CAN'T. TAKE THEIR
ORGANIZATIONAL OF THE ANALYSIS
AND SO. SOME OF THEM HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO DO THAT- ANYWAY WITH
THAT LET'S TURN TO THE
COMMITTEE I KNOW THE CENTER
CASKEY HAS COUPLE QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. YEAH I THINK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I. BECAUSE OF THE
COVERT NINETEEN CRISIS THIS
BILL NORMALLY WOULD GO TO THE
G. FISHER COMMITTEE- I ACTUALLY
SO I SIT ON THAT COMMITTEE I
WILL COMMEND THE AUTHOR OF THE-
THANK STAFF AND YOU MISTER
CHAIR IS THAT. IT I. AGREE AS
THAT THERE'S CERTAIN
SUBSTANTIVE CHANGES TO OUR- THE
SECRET PROCESS I THINK THE ONE
I READ THAT IT REQUIRES A CASE
MANAGEMENT WITHIN THIRTY DAYS I
THOUGHT WATER YOU KNOW WE KNOW
THAT WHEN WE HAVE REQUIRED CASE
MANAGEMENT SAID ALL CIVIL. YOU
SHOULDN'T ALLOW US TO SIT DOWN
WITH THE PARTY YOU CAN FIND OUT
WHAT IS THE DISPUTE THAT'S
GOING ON I THINK A LOT OF TIMES
OKAY I WAS SURPRISED THAT WAS
IN THE REQUIREMENTS PAGE. TEN
UNTIL MAY. AND WHAT IS.
LEVERAGE IN OFFICE THE ACT.
COPY IT MISS PARKER. ISRAELI
TWENTY TWENTY. BOTTOM LINE SOLD
I WILL BE SO THE BILL TODAY AND
I THINK THE AUTHOR FOR. THREE
AND A COMMITTEE STAFFER FROM
REMOVING SEVERAL OBSOLETE
PROVISIONS THAT WE ALWAYS NEED
TO CLEAR FEW CYNICISM NICE
VEHICLE TO USE. OKAY THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. ANY ANY OTHER
GUY I SEE A CENTER STERN IS
NOW- PRESENT- BESSIE CENTER
DOLLY HAS A QUESTION- SEND OUT.
MY OWN THANK YOU AND WHEN THEY
WILL GO TO CENTER STERN.
ACTUALLY I WANT TO JUST SET THE
AUTHOR AND THEN MOVE THE BILL.
OKAY SO BILLS REMOVED BY CENTER
DOLLARS LET'S GO TO YOU CENTER
STERN WELCOME. THANK YOU I
APOLOGIZE FOR MISSING THE PRIOR
DEBATE- BUT- NO NO NO COMMENTS
I JUST WAVE TO SAY HELLO WASN'T.
FISHEL REYES THE HAND APOLOGIES
OKAY MA'AM. THE BILL LOOKS GOOD
APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK OF THE
COMMITTEE OF THE AUTHOR. NO
TROUBLE- THANK YOU THANK YOU
THANK YOU CENTER. LIKE THE
DECOR VERY COOL. ALL RIGHT LET
SOME SO IT'S REMOVED BY SENATOR
DOLLY- IF THERE ARE NO FURTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS- WE CAN
WE CAN ASK THE CONSULTANT TO
OPEN THE ROLE. I DON'T NUMBER
ELEVEN EIGHTY. TWO SEVENTY NINE
BY SOMEONE NUMBER FRIEDMAN. THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
ALLEN. ALLEN AYE DALLI. DALLI
I'M SORRY I CAN'T HEAR YOU BY
DALY I'D THANK YOU HILL.
SKINNER STERN. STERN AYE STERN
AYE WE'RE CASKEY HI MY CASKEY I.
OKAY SO WE'RE GONNA HOLD THE
ROLE OPEN FOR OTHER MEMBERS TO
ADD ON I THINK THAT- CENTERS OF
CASKEY AND DOLLY CAN- CAN MAKE
THEIR WAY OUT I THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN
AT FIRST YEAR ALL YOUR HARD
WORK BILLS. I'M SO CLOSELY WITH
OUR- ALL RIGHT WHEN WE RE OPEN
THE ROLE FOR- FOR CENTER STERN
TO. ADD ON- TO THE EXTENT THAT
HE WOULD LIKE TO. LET'S FIRST
OPEN THE ROLE FOR THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. AND THEN IT ALSO FOR
ME TO BE ASKING ARE SERGEANTS.
HEY IS IT CENTERS CENTER HILL
STILL CHEERING LABOR. YOU GUYS
KNOW. HE'S PRESENTING. I WAS
PRESENTING A BILL OKAY ALL
RIGHT SO JUST ABOUT EASIEST
I'VE NOTICED THAT HE SHOULD
COME BACK WHEN HE'S DONE OKAY
OKAY LET'S LET SOME LET'S OPEN
THE ROLE ON THE CAN STATE
CALENDAR DOES CONSULT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. CONSENT IDMS
NUMBER. TWO THREE FOUR FIVE
EIGHT NINE. AND TEN AGAIN TWO
THREE FOUR FIVE EIGHT NINE AND
TEN- WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I'D
CENTER STERN. STERN AYE STERN
AYE. THAT'S FIVE ZERO OKAY IT'S
MY UNDERSTANDING AND IF ANYONE
HAS A DIFFERENT- STANDING DID
THAT IT SAID BOTH SENATORS
SKINNER AND BATES WILL NOT BE
PARTICIPATING. AND SO WITH THAT
UNDERSTANDING I'M GOING TO BE
CLOSE IN A ROW ON THE CONSENT
COUNT IT'S A FIVE ZERO VOTE AND
THE COUNTER PASSES. OKAY LET'S
NOW GO TO ITEM ONE THIS IS AB
NINE NINETY FIVE CRISTINA
GARCIA IS BILL ON HAZARDOUS
WASTE. D. PASSED THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS. CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL STERN.
JULY STERN AYE. THAT'S FOUR
ZERO. THAT'S FOR THIS YEAR I
BELIEVE IN SENATE DOLLY DID NOT
VOTE ON THAT RIGHT OKAY SO WE
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE ON THAT.
THAT HAS VOTES TO PASS OUT.
PART LET'S NOW GO HE WAS
ALREADY. TO ITEM SIX THIS IS A
SOBRE CORK SPELL THAT WAS
PRESENTED BY OUR GOOD CINEMA
CASKEY THIS IS ON THE FUNDING
STABLE CIVILIZATION PROGRAM AT
THE WATER RESOURCES CONTROL
BOARD. SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
CONSULTANT PLEASE. PLEASE KALRA.
I DON'T NUMBER SIX AB TWENTY
TWO NINETY SIX BY SOME REMEMBER
COURT PROMOTION IS DO PASSED IN
THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE WITH THE CHAIR VOTING
I. KERN HI THREE NINE HILL.
THAT STILL THREE TO ZERO OKAY
SO WILL THAT OPEN I'M IN
COMMUNICATIONS CENTER HILL AND
HE. HE'S IN THE ASSEMBLY S.
INSURANCE HEARING WILL BE WILL
BE HERE SHORTLY OKAY LET'S NOW
GO TO ITEM. SEVEN THIS IS-
FRIEDMAN STATE TWENTY THREE
TWENTY THREE. SO PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL I REMEMBER SEVEN AB
TWENTY THREE TWENTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FREEDOM
FRIEDMAN. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING ON. HILL STERN.
STERN VOTING FOR THE MOMENT
STERN NOT VOTING. OKAY THAT'S
THREE ZERO THREE ZERO SO WE'RE
GONNA LEAVE IT OPEN FOR US- FOR
SENATOR HILL AND TO COME BACK
SO CENTER STERN YOU ARE FREE TO
GO IF YOU LIKE BUT- WE WILL
LATER AND LATER AND- I'M-
ASCENDER HE WILL COME BACK- AND
HE CAN ADD ON TO THOSE. ON TO
THE FINAL THIRTY BILLS I'VE HE
HAS NOT VOTE ON THE FINAL THREE
BILLS. OBVIOUSLY IF WE HAVE ANY
NEWS FROM CENTERS BATES ARE
SKINNER WE WELCOME THEIR
PARTICIPATION IN THEIR VOTES.
LET'S TAKE A VERY RECESSED- AND
WE WILL- WE WILL WAIT FOR
CENTER HELL TO MAKE ITS WAY
OVER HERE.
OKAY EVERYBODY OUT
WE ARE GOING TO. RECONVENES
SUPPOSED TO ALLOW OUR- A GOOD
SENATORS TO ACT ON IT'S IT
TURNS OUT THERE AND THAT WE
NEED TO CLERK NEEDED TO HAVE
BEEN RE VOTE ON ITEM. NUMBER
THAT'S THE B. THIRTY TWO SEVEN.
THE BILL SO LET. I'M SIX THIS
IS AB. TWENTY TWO NINETY SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK. THE
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
THE MOTION IS TO PASS THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
WITH THE CHAIRMAN I NOTICE.
THREE TO ZERO HI. HILL AYE
THAT'S OUR ZERO. OKAY WE'RE
GONNA CLOSE THE ROLE ON THAT.
LET'S NOW. AB TWENTY THREE
TWENTY THREE THIS ITEM SEVEN BY
FRIEDMAN. THIS IS DUE AS
AMENDED TO THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE WITH A
CHAIR VOTING EITHER VOTERS TO
ZERO. HI ILL. STERN ANSWERING
STERN NOT VOTING THE VOTE IS
FOUR TWO ZERO. OKAY WE'RE NEXT
GOING TO GO WHERE CLOSER ON
THAT AS WELL LET'S NOW GO TO
ITEM NUMBER LET B. TO SEVENTY
FRIEDMAN. THE RAW EMOTION. THE
SENATE COMMITTEE WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I'D VOTE IS FOUR TO ZERO
HILL HI HILL HI. SENATOR START
STERN TURN AYE VOTE IS. FIVE
TWO ZERO OKAY WHAT CLOSER ON
THAT IS I THINK THAT NOW-
COMPLETES ALL OF OUR BUSINESS.
ONCE AGAIN DO VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE HARD WORK OF
OUR- STAFF BOTH OUR FLOOR STAFF
HERE IN THE STATE AND ALSO
OBVIOUSLY THE ENVIRONMENT BUT
HE CANSTOP. YOU CENTER HEALTH
FOR COME BACK FOR THE- THANK
YOU CENTER STERN MISTER DID YOU
NEED IT WELCOME. ARE WONDERFUL
PRESIDED OVER BY STAFF AND THE
CHAIR WELL DONE ON ALL FRONTS
WILL PRECEDE YOU. CENTERS AND-
THAT WE WILL- WE WILL WE WILL
ADJOURN THIS HEARING AND WE
WILL BE BACK REMEMBER EVERYBODY
WILL BE BACK ON FRIDAY. WICH
THE START TIME IT'S GONNA
PARTLY BASED ON. BUT IT WILL BE
BACK HERE IN THIS CHAMBER
FRIDAY. AROUND MIDDAY WILL BE
WILL BE STARTING UP TO FINISH.
THIS YEAR'S AGENDA WITH THE
COMMITTEE SO. MANY WHAT WILL
ADJOURN THIS HEARING.